Film Courage: Shane by the time you'd finished
what the fifth grade you'd already had
a hundred films and commercials under your
belt do you remember those days? Shane Stanley,
Author/Filmmaker:: i remember those days um as a
youngster working in in hollywood i got my start
and i was born in 1971 and the same year century
21 became a thing it was a big real estate company
and a friend of my father's uh was producing
a series of commercials for them and he said
we're trying to appeal to young families looking
to buy homes we need it we can't find a kid that
can sit and behave long enough to get these takes
done and you know i was literally sitting in the
corner chewing on something and my dad said won't
you take him so i started as a baby actor in front
of the camera those days i don't remember my first
memory of working on set was with june lockhart
you know from lassie and i worked with june
on some projects that my father was producing
and then lloyd haynes from room 222 uh ron masak
who i'm still very dear with who's ron's been in
everything from harper valley pta torre tortora
he was a velocic pickle stork murder she wrote
and then was on um whitney in a robot with david
arkin back for nbc before i was seven years old
um so i grew up doing a lot of on-camera work as
a youngster and what was really interesting is my
father got a contract with encyclopedia britannica
to do all their what they called burns and poisons
and general safety films the educational films of
the 70s why was that kid i was that kid that was
riding his bike across the street without looking
both ways and got hit i was the kid who ran out in
the street after his frisbee or his baseball
and got hit i was i was getting hit by cars
in my dad's video um you know the kid that got
electrocuted because he put the paper clip in the
in the socket and what was weird was this was
mandated viewing in all the schools growing up so
we would have these assemblies and it was kind of
weird because you were stuck with 500 kids in this
auditorium watching your your video and they'd
watch you get electrocuted i got to drown a couple
times i was the kid who got in the pool and you
know went after something when nobody's looking
and drowned and yeah that was that was how i
started my career it reminds me of scared straight
do you remember that i know it well i remember it
just kind of reminds me of that was also mandatory
viewing yeah that's right it was it was so so
long story longer is my father he had been a
successful actor in the 70s you know and fell in
love with filmmaking so he went all out and bought
a moviola flatbed a couple of re-16 cameras
that he had and at a very young age i started
learning how to splice film run the moviola use
an ra16 and be an assistant you know whether i
was doing the slate or assisting the editors that
would come in to sync sound or splice film and
i actually enjoyed that kind of work a lot more
than showing up on a set sitting around for six
hours to get 20 minutes of work in very
young so i retired in front of the camera
probably before i was 11 or 12. those days were
behind me but then by the time you were 19 you
had won two emmys yeah i was nominated for four
emmys before my 19th birthday and one and two okay
blessing or curse um you know it sure was a
blessing that night you know i was the toast
of the town i remember going to the after parties
and hitting all those restaurants being that that
16 year old kid walking around with an emmy in the
restaurant that was cool but you go back to school
life goes on and i was not sure what i wanted
to do with my life i was very fortunate to
have the opportunity to work in the industry but
i i wasn't passionate about it i wanted to be
a drummer for a season i wanted to race dirt bikes
for another season and and my interest kind of
followed that and i'd always get back into working
in our industry because dad was doing a project he
needed help um you know hey somebody needs an ac
that guy that worked on our last film needs to
hire an assistant cameraman i want you to go work
with him for the day so i always got pulled back
in and didn't try and i think the curse was here's
somebody who didn't put much thought or effort
into what i did and had four emmy noms and two
wins before i had really been a year out of high
school before i was old enough to drink i was i
was that deep and when i finally decided to pursue
this industry i made a decision to put the emmys
in a closet i got rid of them out of sight out of
mind for probably 10 years started at the bottom
my father had a wonderful assistant janet stone
who uh used to work at castle rock for allens with
belle and larry david and i called her one day and
said i want to get into this industry i want to
start from the ground up i want to start over
and and re re pave the way to where i need to go
and she made a phone call for me and i had taken
a couple interviews and was working at castle rock
uh shortly after and got fired from them after a
year and uh was the best thing ever happened to me
because i learned that you know what i thought i
knew didn't matter i learned how to become a good
listener didn't matter what i had achieved or done
before fortunately there wasn't the internet or
imdb so people didn't look up their pa to see
what my history was so i started from
the ground up and worked with castle
rock for about a year and a half on shows like
seinfeld seaquest all-american girl roseanne
and then after getting fired wound up working for
entertainment tonight for a year and a half until
viacom took over the studio and then from then
went freelance and figured it out just started
working wherever i could doing whatever i could
what did getting fired teach you what it really
taught me was is you know you can still put the
emmys in the closet but you still have a sense of
belonging you still don't feel like the bottom guy
in the totem pole even though i was i was hired as
the office pa at you know 447 at universal
studios during taping of a lot of these big
sitcoms so i was nothing and i think because of my
upbringing and because of what i had experienced
i naturally felt like i had a sense of belonging
that may have not been warranted just because of
my own history and that was on me i knew i was
in trouble when they had a very famous director
by the name of john rich come in to direct
one of the episodes john had done the brady
bunch he's been around um i think he did sound of
music um wasn't john rich it was another director
bobby wise forgive me forgive me and um i was told
nobody's allowed to talk to him he's a legend if
you're below the line you don't look at him you
don't talk to him well i walk down the hall to
deliver my smart and final run and bobby wise is
in the cafeteria making himself a sandwich or a
bowl of soup and i said mr wise how you doing
he looked at me and he goes what's up kid and i
said wells roots my uh my godfather lee stanley's
my dad and he stopped everything gave me argues
what are you doing here let's let's hang out and
i think because i did what i shouldn't have done
um it showed my bosses that i don't listen well i
didn't care what they said i wanted to do what i
wanted to do and i only did that because because
he was a true friend of the family my godfather
and him had done three movies together and
i knew who he was and i got fired over that
wow so i learned quick uh follow directions
it's interesting though we won't go too deep
into this but how sometimes it's not actually
that if someone's ego was offended but anyway
that i could i could tell you it was the
showrunner's husba showrunner's wife was
my boss and uh when i got fired it was pretty
interesting i got brought in by the upm who was
a wonderful human being who worked for castle rock
he said look you did nothing wrong technically
it's just a weird dynamic man he goes you know
you're not supposed to talk to a guy and you
end up knowing this guy and i mean this guy
had been out of my dad's boat three times i
mean that's how i knew i mean why not say
hi to him but i was told don't talk to him
i should have told my boss look he's an old
family friend and i didn't but and those are
the yeah the unwritten rules of hollywood that
sometimes we learn unfortunately hence your your
book that you will go more into thank you yeah
okay do you think if you had been in your 40s
and had won those two emmys or been nominated for
four that it would have been a sweeter victory or
you don't really think about that it's just
been your life you know that's a great question
i think at the end of the day i often i i i went
through a phase where i assumed up until i was 40
that i had peaked at 16 or 17 or 18. i think
that's a dangerous thing i mean i talk about
i was very fortunate very young to be a part of
something that was successful it wasn't me it was
the team and i was just a lucky recipient i mean
we had 33 emmy noms in five years when i think we
won 13 or 14 emmys so i was very fortunate to be a
part of that because of my camera work or the the
other production work that i did on these shows
but you know you get to know childhood actors
growing up like macaulay culkin or adam rich was
a friend of mine or you know working with charlie
sheen for many years and we talk about peaking
at a young age you know charlie's great success
obviously he had tremendous success through many
years capping it with two and a half men in anger
management but you think about platoon and wall
street how that all happened before he was really
before he's 22 years old um you talked to
adam rich about the success he had as a
youngster gary coleman and i i always felt i
could connect with those guys because of that
i understood what it was like to be very lucky
to be very fortunate to be a part of something
i never took it for granted i never used
it i don't think to my advantage but
i couldn't help but think as i was going through
my 20s and 30s as i was trying to find my way
and create and write and produce or direct
or edit films i i got to get this this kind
of success i got to achieve this and though i
had success through those years it wasn't until
i was about 40 or 41 maybe it's that midlife
crisis they all tell us that you get at 40.
that i i realized that i was chasing something
that i was never going to never achieve again
it didn't mean i'd never win an emmy again but i
wasn't going to win another one at 16. i was 40.
and you know so you see people go through it
every year hundreds of people win a statue
that could be me again it might not be um but i
think the excitement of it was the fact that i
was so young and that's what made it special and
you can't go backwards you can't go back in time
does the film industry make people
crazy and if not why that perception
yeah i think there's a a lot of crazy that
comes hand in hand with being an artist
anyway there's an eccentricity with creative
beings we're dreamers i think any time you you
live your life based on kind of playing the odds
of the lottery how does it not make you crazy as
i talk about in my book what other business do
you know of really you know music film dance
art where you could literally be homeless living
on a friend's couch and get an audition for that
one role and become the next gal gadot you could
become the next you know jason bateman you can be
anybody and you know you think about doctors
lawyers successful business people they they
have a path they still may be trying to figure out
that path but they usually go to college they'll
often figure out a plan and a road get get their
eye on a prize and work their way to it you know
medical school being six years and then residency
that's that's a game plan for artists for what we
do the game plan is bust your ass you know make it
you'll fake it till you make it you know it's it's
never give up it's i can't quit because my break
may come tomorrow and i think a lot of people uh
coming up that way and trying to find their path
uh in their place it can make you crazy i've found
trying to find my path has made me a little nuts
sometimes as i say a little south of sanity um i
also find once we get in a position of authority
it's i think no other industry is as uh is unkind
as ours and i know everybody says there's horrible
people in every industry i've been around every
industry you can imagine because of what i do
and the things that i've experienced and shot
and i it it's mind-boggling how people are treated
and yeah the i think the me too movement and then
the aftermath of that and people and how we talk
to one another was so long overdue but it's it's
amazing what people get away with and i still
think they get away with it know how they talk
to each other and treat people i and i that that
can make people crazy you know i think it does
sure what about people's reactions to artists
you know there's all these sort of stigmas that
artists are selfish or whatever can we talk about
other people's reactions can i swear uh okay one
swear word one f mom okay i i have a brother who
i i love more than anything he's very successful
and he has a motto that he's always kind of looked
at what with what we do and he's always said look
you want to be an artist go paint in a [ __ ]
park on saturday get a job life's a business don't
don't you know life's life goes by fast you don't
want to look back when you're 40 or 50 and wonder
what happened you know he's the smart squirrel
that always stashed away during the winter
you know for the winter months and i i see that
i i came from a my mother was from manhattan uh
from new york a very successful lawyer was her
father she was a very successful real estate agent
her brother is a you know was the
director of primary care for kaiser
and the fact that i didn't go to college
the fact that i just wanted to be a dreamer
uh figure out what i'm gonna do with myself and
you know the three choices i picked were were
music dirt bikes and films so you don't need
a college education for either and all of them
are pretty pretty big shots in the dark i think
people look at artists and uh as i call us um
you know people who who express themselves for
a living a lot of people don't understand it i
i find when i talk with different schools
different institutions a lot of parents
um are more supportive now than they
were when i was growing up because
you have things like you know somebody like
mark zuckerberg coming along and creating
facebook you have somebody who created twitter or
pinterest and all these things that one day they
they wrote a code for something that made him a
billionaire overnight so i think we have a little
more leeway and a little more grace from
people who look down at the dreamers and the
the creative beings but i still i still get sad
when i talk to a lot of the the youngsters coming
up and it's like they don't have the support from
their family especially the ones that are going
to community college because they don't have the
financial means to put themselves to a good school
and they certainly don't have the support of
parents i actually encounter some very well to do
people in the community colleges whose parents are
like i'll write the check to go to usc tomorrow
you want to go to yale we'll make it happen
but you're going to go down this path you're
on your own and i think that's unfortunate um
so i think there's a little bit of a stigma
still um but i don't think it's as bad as it was
when when i was coming up do you think people and
community colleges i know we're going off on a
little bit of a tangent but are less competitive
with one another i mean i went to a community
college at that time the internet was just
starting up so you couldn't look somebody up and
say oh what's this person's deal so you could be
more anonymous but i felt like it wasn't like uber
competitive and i was able to enjoy myself there
i've gotten to the point where whenever a
community college says would you could you
can you the answer is yes because there's a purity
there is a drive there is a determination without
prejudice i find a lot of the people at community
colleges now are on their second their second wave
of life they're often parents they take buses and
public modes of transportation to get to school
they're putting themselves through you know
paying a few hundred dollars a unit to try to get
to something and i enjoy that crowd a lot um
i do work with a lot of universities and i
appreciate and cherish that time too but the
mindset is different um i can tell you without
naming names there are universities that accept
the fact that their students will not finish their
thesis film after having three years to do it and
they still get a beautiful diploma and march down
march down the uh the stage and i i don't
understand that our business will not
hire you if you don't finish a task if
you don't show up and you don't deliver
you don't work so i don't know why you'd reward
them and and i had a chair at a very prominent
film school university tell me once we don't
want to deal with the lawsuits so we passed
them and if i'm breaking protocol by coming out
and saying that i don't care that's how it is
and that doesn't happen at community
college you have guys like dan watanabe and
chris rossiter and some wonderful teachers who
have been that and done there and spent more time
on a set than most university professors have and
they are very happy to fail you uh if you don't
do the work and i appreciate that because that's
how it is remember alex p keaton from family times
he was always marty mcfly he was always throwing
community colleges under the bus that was his like
go-to thing but i i think they are salt of the
earth and i and i i it's funny i will tell you
when they first when i first wrote my book and a
few of the universities were getting excited and
a few blacklisted me and just by the title of
the book because i used to be welcome to give
lectures and workshops and speak and then as
soon as they read the manuscript it was oh
well the title of your book you're out and
it's like i have no problem with film school
if you didn't grow up around it you need to learn
these things all i want to do is teach you what
they don't teach you there's the business of the
business of distribution and how to get financing
you know not french new year or what angle to put
the camera and the lights at there's so much more
to learn doing your own deals production deals
distribution agreements actor agreements how to
approach talent how to approach money you don't
talk about that in film school that's what i
that's what i teach and when i first got people
excited about the book and it started like well
you know there's there's nine community colleges
out where you are and we'd really love to get you
roped in with them i at first was a little
kind of like what am i getting into here
and i went and spoke for my first time at a
community college and i never looked back i
loved the passion these people had and they're not
kids we have people our age there i mean there's
i go to some of these workshops there's people in
their 60s and 70s trying to figure out their next
chapter and i love that they've been that done
there they're old souls they've lived they've
scrapped for everything they've got they've
fought for every piece of real estate they own
usually and i i just think that makes for better
artists i think it makes for better human beings
shane in your book what you don't learn in film
school you say you've been rich and you've been
poor you like rich better what did each experience
teach you what happened how did you get from point
a to point b and back you know i've been rich i've
been poor and i of course you like rich better you
want to be able to take your loved ones out to
dinner you want to be able to take a vacation
you want to be able to pay a mortgage bill or
a phone bill when it comes in without breaking
a sweat and figuring out where that's going to
come from um you know when you when you start out
you know i was very stubborn i wanted to
prove my independence maybe it came from
being unlucky enough to win two emmys before my
19th birthday but you know for my 18th birthday
i graduated high school on my 18th birthday june
15 1989 i was in my first condo living on my own
within a couple months after that i moved right
out and my parents didn't want me to leave they
didn't they weren't saying hey get your life
together you need to get a house or move out i
just was like wanted my independence and you know
it was amazing you don't when you're not educated
like me in the fundamentals of life
sense i was an old soul when it came
to dealing with the things that i had seen
and experienced and witnessed as a young kid
but i you know really taught me how to
balance a checkbook nobody taught me about
where to put money or how to how to manage money
so i was that kid that would make five grand and
spend 10 you know the next day just assuming and
then forgetting there were taxes and bills and
you know so i um i learned very quickly how fast
money goes i learned very quickly how you have to
promote yourself to work we're we're sales people
in this industry we're we're selling widgets which
are ourselves we're selling a product whether
it's a script or us as an actor or a filmmaker
and i learned what it's like to file bankruptcy
when i was in my 20s i learned what it was like to
be evicted when i was in my 20s i learned what it
was like to have a car repossessed when i was in
my 20s and then another car repossessed when i was
in my 20s and another car repossessed after that
in my 20s so you know finally a light goes on and
say okay this isn't working and then you learn how
to manage and then you know you have success you
work hard you know it's fortunate i was a part of
some successful projects and i liked rich better
because i wasn't getting my cars repossessed
and i was able to go to nice dinners when
i felt like it and i was able to you know
pay rent or mortgage and not sweat um plus those
are some big guys repossessing those cars there's
some big guys and i learned at a young age not to
fight them either i learned the hard way when they
don't collect no they don't mess around those guys
because they don't get paid unless they bring a
car back and you know i didn't know that you know
and those crowbars they have that they they they
don't mind swinging at them i mean they'll they'll
hit you with them but uh anyway um so i when when
it came around again i learned to be a little
bit more responsible not to live outside my means
and i i i'm not rich or poor now i i make
a living being a filmmaker i'm comfortable
um i don't ever take anything for granted i
don't regret any decisions i've made or what
i've experienced um sure we'd all like to to be
able to just thumb our nose and only do what we
want when we want but that's not what life's about
i've been in those chapters where you know you can
go four or five years and not worry about work and
it's easy to become complacent it's easy to become
put things in cruise control and lose the edge
lose the venom as i say and i find when i think
of myself in a situation of needing to provide
for my family when i think about needing to keep
a roof over my head and wanting to be able to
have a nice dinner once a month or to take a
little road trip with my wife it reminds me i
got to keep my my nose to the grindstone and i
never get complacent i'm always grinding can we
can we hear a story about a great time where you
you had the 5 000 payout and spent 10 and then
maybe times when yeah things were really bad and
i'll give you a better one i remember the 25 000
days those were the fun ones you know when you get
a phone call out of the blue it's like hey we need
you to do a commercial it only pays 25 grand but
we'll only need you for five hours can you come in
sure i'll be there and you know and i had a loan
out company so they'd take out taxes so you know
you're getting a check for 25 grand and that's
for like four hours of work that doesn't it's not
a bad day you know or i remember selling a script
um my first screenplay i ever sold i got 125
thousand dollars for it i wrote it in two weeks
it doesn't happen often but you forget about
agents managers lawyers business managers taxes
that that 125 grand turned into about fifty one
thousand dollars really quick i had already bought
two new cars four jet skis two motorcycles
and took a bunch of friends to vegas so
you know stupid is easy come easy go right so
you know that happens um as far as being broke i
i remember uh renting a house and knowing deep
down inside i couldn't maintain it but boy it
sure looked good at the moment and made me
feel like the king of the mountain because
it was on top of a mountain in the valley and i
remember after three months getting a call from
the landlord he's like i'm sure you know but
you know you're check bounced and i was like
okay and i'm looking at my bank statement i
got 320 to my name i just bounced to 2600 check
yeah you know and then you're you're robbing
peter to pay paul to to make rent and uh
next thing you know you're you're living with
a buddy in his two-bedroom apartment paying him
300 bucks until he could figure it out again
and you know because of this crazy business
i got a phone call and went off and did a
five million dollar movie six weeks later
and i was back at it again you know making good
money all in the unions and it's crazy business
so what i've learned to do is is to just just
be and treat every every job as your last
and every dime that you get that you may never get
another and i'm not stingy you just become more
prudent as you get older you know i'm going
to be 50 next year you know i don't want to
have to keep hustling when i'm 70. i'd like to do
only what i want to do when i'm 70. and i've been
lucky i get to do what i want to do but there's
still the desire to get out and work so i don't
have to worry those friends that you took to
vegas do you still talk to them incidentally no no
no so when the money went away those friends
went away it's like you hear about all the
sports athletes and rock stars and the
actors that when it's good it's good and
when it's bad it's bad it's the same for us
behind the scenes guys you know when you're
19 20 21 years old and you're burning through
250 300 000 a year living on your own without
any responsibilities you're the life of the
party and then when you got to start telling
your friends you know that's why i bought so many
jet skis because i wanted my friends to come out
and jet ski with me they couldn't afford their own
so i'll buy three or four let's go out together
and then you know they call you and say hey
let's go jet skiing this weekend and you're like
yeah i sold them well those group of friends fall
away and then you know hey i need to borrow your
your truck this week i i got to do something well
i don't have the truck anymore i've only got my
you know my my two-seater right now or my
four-seater cars like oh and then those people
go away you know it's just like fairweather
friends sure i i have some great friends i've
known all my life but the people that went to
vegas back then no i don't see them anymore
shane in your new book what you don't learn in
film school was there a chapter or section that
sparked controversy oh absolutely um i think the
most controversial chapter in the book is the one
that's the most important and that's to get out
dig ditches get your hands dirty and make yourself
available and whatever it takes to get on a set
within your morals values and ethics parameter to
go do it and when i came up as we talked about how
i made phone calls and hustled to get work and get
on sets i worked for free i brought my own lunch
i showed up first and left last i was sweeping
floors when it wasn't in my job description and
i have close friends that our generation grew up
you know i have a friend whose father won two
oscars and his mother has nine emmys you want
to talk about nepotism and when he got his act
together like i did he said hey you know yeah
i want to work in this business i want to be an
editor mom picked up the phone made a phone call
okay he'll be there tomorrow two o'clock perfect
thank you click you got a job you're sweeping
floors it color deluxe you're getting paid nothing
pack a launch deer and he swept floors deluxe
for two years i think it was deluxe and he didn't
have a problem with that he thought that's normal
i had won emmys at a young age and started over
and we talked about not being able to make rent
well there was something called crew call back
when i was coming up and you would literally
subscribe for like 50 a month you would call
an 800 number and you would say you know press
one for camera press two for sound press three for
you know electric and you would press these things
that you could do and then you would hear about
jobs and you would write it down and it would give
you a fax number and you would fax your resume you
would spend a day a week doing that and pray your
phone rang and sometimes it wouldn't so a friend
would call and say hey i need a i need a swing
in the camera department tomorrow i pay lunch
you enter out and i was like yeah i'm there
the biggest problem i have today is when i talk
to film schools or when people read that chapter
about having to invest in yourself and build your
resume you know so many people are in my opinion
in film school are sold on hopes and dreams and
um being the next tarantino or damian chazelle
and my advice is well if that doesn't happen
what's the game plan so get out and learn
camera learn sound learn editing learn
grit learn gaff learn ac whatever you can
and if somebody can't pay you to do something
and you have an opportunity to make new contacts
learn and be on a set something good will come
from that do you would you rather sit home and
play on your phone or play xbox or watch repeated
streaming shows that you've seen six times you
want to get out and make new contacts and i find a
lot of people uh think that's not the way to do it
and i also think okay well over 85 percent of
people who spend money and graduate from film
schools never earn a dime in our industry and
there's a reason for it and that's because they
are uneducated on how to make their lives work
and how to build a career base and contacts and
become steady earners in our business and the way
i did it the way i know a lot of people who did it
was they got out there and proved their worth
by hustling and some of the best workers like
we just felt finished a film called break even
that comes out some of the best workers on that
film were the interns from lake pierce
college there's a kid that stands out
he worked so hard every day never said a word
head down he anticipated everybody's needs he
was the guy that was cleaning up everybody's
trash at the end of the night showed up on
days he wasn't supposed to be there just because
he wanted to check in say i'm coming in tomorrow
does anybody need anything you know what i always
tell people is when you make a movie and you're
trying to carve your way make it so the decision
makers don't want to make a movie without you
and every time you do a film you sure meet a
lot of people you never want to make another
movie with but it's nice when you see those one
or two diamonds in a rough that you say god i
i want to bring them back and they were they were
somebody who was a pa they were an assistant they
were a runner and i think if people take that
approach as as i say in the book um whenever
you offer somebody a job it's what's my credit
what's my pay it's always the first question
what's my credit what's my pay and i think it
needs to be okay you know take a breath and think
about what the experience can do for you i mean
i talked in the same chapter i talk about the the
best thing i ever did for my career was say yes
to something i knew nothing about i did it for
free and it took up a month and a half of my life
and that was going to bali indonesia with zalman
king when he directed in god's hands solomon had
seen my work ethic around a sound stage he owned
in canoga park i was sweeping floors and he's
like he walked in and he goes i thought you were
producing or doing something more important
i said yeah everybody left i wanted to leave
your studio the way we found it and he says what's
your name and he came over and he talked to me and
we befriended each other and he came and visited
the next day on set and next thing you know he
called me up and he said hey what are you doing
in november or december and i said i don't know
what do you got and he said well i'm doing a
film in bally i think i think uh you should come
i said do what he said shadow me learn he goes
i'll offer you free education working with me and
and we'll feed you and travel you and you figure
out the rest you didn't pay me a dime and it was
it was like talk about film school you're sitting
next to zalman freaking king as he's directing a
movie for a major studio and i was on his hip for
a month and a half doing that and i learned more
by just saying yes and then ask what
i get a credit and what i get paid
you know and they limited me to the airport and
first class me round trip gave me my own bungalow
and in a five-story resort i didn't ask for any
of that i didn't i probably know i'd be sleeping
in a tube tent on the side of a mountain you
know but they took care of me and uh i think
that's the attitude obviously you don't want
to be taken advantage of you don't want to get
into a situation that's not healthy but there
seems to be such resistance in getting out and
experiencing work without worrying about pay
there's too many people that'll do it do you
think that's because for you know our generation
gen x that there wasn't the term intern you know
and some of the let's play the devil's advocate
yes interns can be taken advantage of in terms of
absolutely people using free labor and and not
stringing them along and not giving them a job is
that what they're afraid of i don't know i think
honestly um i think as a society we would become
pretty tender i think we become very sensitive and
i think people are afraid of exploitation which i
think is something we all need to consider but
you know i i know i've got a nephew who worked
as his you know what off working for a financial
institution in arizona and scottsdale working 18
hours a day getting their lunch cleaning up
their mess getting them coffee you didn't get
paid much at all but now he's an actual worker
in that industry and he used that after colleges
wasn't for college credits he graduated college
his dad made a few phone calls and said you're
going to go sweat you're going to wear a tie and
you're going to go you're going to go ride their
their wave you're not going to get paid you're
going to learn it happens in other industries but
it's just seems in ours i think it's because
the hours are abused you know and if in a normal
workplace it's an eight-hour work day with an
hour break in film it's 10-12 if you're lucky and
i think people are afraid they're going to
be working 16 18 hours a day as free labor
so it's hard to say why but i never questioned
that i maybe maybe it was just the fact that i
could be on a set and make connections and learn
and i always figured well i could sit at home and
wait for the phone to ring or i could be on a
set and meet a director or a producer who may
find my my job skills necessary to bring me to the
next journey and then make a great connection and
say by the way i have a script by the way you
know i also do camera can i get an opportunity
and it doesn't happen by sitting at home it
just doesn't great okay excellent at least
i don't think it does i mean you can upload
youtube and vimeo until you're blue in the face
yeah but working with you know being around
people is is a different experience absolutely
there's good and bad best gigs and best
opportunities i ever had in my life were
showing up and working hard and proving myself
as a worker who was competent and the people in
the decision-making capacities going out of their
way to say hey you know appreciate your work today
thank you and then you know we've got something
coming up next week i want to get you on that
and then they start to appreciate you and
you work these gigs and next thing you know
you have an audience you have an ear with the
decision makers and when you want to move up in
the world or they know people that will benefit
by knowing you that's all it is in this business
what caused you to leave the film industry for
what two years two years i did to do some soul
searching i i i needed a break i you know i i got
my first national commercial i was nine months old
i had gone through the highs and lows the
riches and poor's been through a divorce
marriage and a divorce rather quickly and you
know as i used to say my life was trying to have a
like having a picnic at the runway
at that time in my life it was very
just very a lot going on it's very turbulent and
i i was approaching 30 i was in my late 20s and
you kind of hit rock bottom emotionally i
wasn't you know suicidal i wasn't destitute
but i was emotionally done i had been doing one
thing and one thing only for so long even though i
i dabbled in other hobbies or career paths suggest
you know ideas coming up i had only done one thing
and i i needed a break i just needed you know it's
one of those things is this really what i want to
do is this something i want to continue doing
is this something i want to pursue and put the
next chapter or the next 30 years of my life
into you know when you start coming up on 30
you do a lot of soul searching you're
not a kid anymore you know your 20s are
coming up being over and you got to start thinking
you know things haven't gone as i thought they
would or i hope they would is this something i
want to keep doing and it was the best thing i
ever did i actually went and sold cars i went
and sold cars for a ford dealership for galp
and ford and it happened by accident i was having
lunch with the owner's son we were good friends
and his father came in who owned a dealership he
came in he looked at me and he said you look like
you don't look too good and he said you look like
your soul's been bought and sold down a river
a half a dozen times and i said yeah it's been a
rough go i'm going through a divorce going through
bankruptcy and i'm just you know business closed
down one of my partners went a little cuckoo
and he said well why don't you come sell cars
and i said what are you nuts i sell cars and he
looked at me and he said you've been peddling that
crap you call art for the last 20 years you made
a living doing that you got the number one ford
dealer in the world cars sell themselves you never
went to college you don't know how to do anything
other than what you do why don't you learn and get
an education learn how to listen learn how to
sell he goes i promise you when you quit here
if you decide not to stay you will take what
you learn here and be better at what it is
you think you can do and boy was he right
that was my college education selling cars
what was that first morning like
getting ready to go to galpin
well they stuck me in a four-week training
course so i went and learned how to sell
for four weeks under lou brown who was a
very world-renowned car sales guru that
used to tour the world and teach salesmen
getting ready to hit the floor how to sell
i could i would always been told i could sell
ice to an eskimo and we had 18 graduates in my
class and i was the last one to sell a car it
took me three and a half weeks to move a car and
it got to the point where my boss pulled me aside
and said if you don't sell a car today i'm gonna
tr i'm gonna request you to be transferred
or fired because you're you're not you're not
moving anything and there was a cop that used to
drive by the dealership he lived in palmdale he
worked at lapd nicest guy in the world he used
to stop by and visit me every other day and you
know he would just he i encountered him one day
on the lot and we hit it off and i you know i
have a heart for cops and he was a neat guy and
i thought he wanted to buy a ford explorer and he
would talk to me about it every day and finally
you know at that time my boss yelled to me said
you don't sell he showed up the guy showed up that
he said you don't sell him a car today you're done
so i walked out and he wanted to see me and i'm
walking around a lot with him and i he looked at
me and he said you seem a little like something's
up what's on your mind you know he's a cop they're
intuitive right he was a detective he's like
what's going on you see him a little i said
sir if you don't buy a car for me today i'm
going to get fired and he goes you're kidding
me your boss said that and i said yeah and he
goes well we can't have that happen i like it
in the blue let's wrap this up never saw him
again he bought the car and never saw him again
the cool thing is i sold another car that day
and then i started to become a good salesman
it was just about doing that and that's what
i try to use in teaching a lot of the kids
about writing their first screenplay uh going on
their first audition working on their first show
shooting your first project even if it's on your
phone until you do it you don't know what it's
like and once you do it it gets easier and you'll
fail you'll make a lot of mistakes do it again
fail again but every time you do it you're not
going to make the same mistake twice it's like
i've been at this a long time i've been
a producer filmmaker going on 30 years
and i make mistakes every time i i make a film i
make i make mistakes but i don't make them twice
so every time i make a movie i make a new
mistake and then next time i know i won't
make that mistake again and you grow you grow
and and that's what i try to encourage the young
the young storytellers coming up is it's okay
to fail fail often get it out of your system
when did you feel you were ready to go back in you
had sold some cars maybe you got your confidence
back up i worked i committed to do a year i ended
up working 18 months with galpin and it was the
most incredible years of my life i'm still very
close to the ownership i'm still very close to
a lot of people i sold cars with and i'm still
close to some of the customers i sold cars to
i was in 18 months there were some issues with a
manufacturer that was not ford but that was very
public when they had tires that were ripping
off of cars and i had sold probably 300 ford
explorers over my 18 months there and i came into
the office one day and had over 300 messages on my
my phone after taking a weekend off and it was
customers freaking out and i realized that this
is probably a bit more than i this is this is
it's time and and it that i had been nurturing
that i had passed on two movies that had come to
me during the time i was there because i wanted to
commit to to the family that that brought me a job
and provided me a very good living working there
and an opportunity but it was the it was the fire
debacle with the ford explorers that was the end
for me that's when i turned in my uh my name plate
and turned over my sales books and said it's i'll
give you two weeks and they said we don't do that
here you know we don't and that's just a policy
because they don't want you taking customers in
case you sell cars elsewhere which i never did but
i that's why i left i was that was it was time and
i stepped right into a great film that i did with
my father and uh never looked back and that was in
1998 99. have you ever thought about taking that
story of working for the car dealership working
for galpin and turning it into a screenplay
i've thought about turning my experiences into
working in the car sales business many times
um there was a great film done years ago called
suckers which shows the dark side of a dealership
now the cool thing about a dealership in gallpin
is a first class organization i mean they're
the best in the world at what they do but there's
still the the people that work there that make it
interesting the family runs a tight ship they're
the best in the business they sell more cars than
anybody but you still have the riffraff's and i
say that with with with fun because what i what
i learned is in lou brown's class he said nobody
sells cars for a living because they said i want
to sell cars for a living people if you think
about it everybody who sells cars didn't grow
up single and sell cars they failed at something
else they they went through a divorce they they
had hardships they lost to business and and it
was so true i remember in our class that we had
18 people graduate 35 of us started everybody else
had a story about a career that failed or a job
that closed down or a divorce or a circumstance
so you have these unbelievable people from all
walks of life from all nationalities all different
classes of financial and background and pedigree
but there was a film called suckers that i
watched and it it was so scary on the nose
when it came to the business of the
business that i thought you can never
you're never gonna touch that so i developed a tv
series that when i was working with david madden
at fox i got very excited about i was developing
tv shows for fox when david was there and um
everybody loved the concept they thought it was
great but you'll notice there's a reason that
car sale shows are not on tv and that's because
the number one sponsorships of your ad dollars
are usually car sales car manufacturers
you know you've got mazda you got buick
you got honda you got chevy you got kia it's
endless and they take those prime time slots to
show families what they could be driving so if you
are going to tell the true story of the business
you're not going to get those ad dollars
so i found through some really high up
connections in in television sales broadcasting
and decision makers that you're not the first
who's come with the idea it's a great idea that we
can't touch because that's where our dollars come
from so but now that there's a streaming ability
i should recircle that you know that's something
worth thinking about because you know if you're
doing a show on netflix you're not worried about
selling cadillac commercials this is off topic a
little bit but then glenn gary glenn ross was okay
wall street wolf of wall like so it's okay to see
one sector of sales yeah but that was in car sales
right it's it's the fact that
buick if you watch a network show
watch this as us i know you're probably doing what
i do and skipping through your commercials on dvr
i guarantee you a third of the ads you see on
any show are going to be from car manufacturers
if you show a show that shows the dark side of
that business how do you get a car company to
pay for ads of that show you're going to have a
hole in the advertising but you're right but those
were films glengarry gun ross was a great film
wolf of wall street great film but wall street
is its own thing they're not buying ad dollars
they're just you know pulling the strings of our
globe any way you like but i i just thought of it
as we're sitting here talking is you know you can
do series for amazon you can do them for netflix
you can do them for all sorts of different outlets
that don't require ad dollars coming in so
maybe it's time to dust off some of those and
and it's also nice because you can kind of
cross some lines and push the envelope on those
platforms too you could do an ensemble thing
like with crash where you you focus different
different stories people getting ready to go to
his training class anyway best thing i ever had
happen is i remember taking a family of six
i remember taking a very nice conservative
family of sex on a test drive in a uh i forgot i
think was the wind star ford windstar family van
and i remember the father was driving and
the mother was sitting and i'm sitting in
the next rows with all the kids and
all of a sudden the father he's doing
like 55 60 miles an hour down to poverty
boulevard he looks up slams on the brakes
and what happened was one of the salesmen
had taken a nap in the back of the windstar
and woke up during the test drive and father's
driving all of a sudden this guy with his
hair all disheveled it could have been a
porter or somebody popped up from the back
i mean that's kind of that happens at dealerships
i mean you're dealing with crazy people walks like
they're party animals i've partied with you know
poison guns and roses motley crew and van gaal and
all in the same night with charlie sheen on the
side and i will tell you the people that work at
car dealerships they can drink them all under the
table i kid you not that's a whole different breed
that's awesome sorry no that's really funny that's
really funny that's a great story without naming
names can you tell us a story about how a studio
took was it your script or one of your ideas which
time um i i'm really a big proponent on protecting
your work i will go on record to say don't waste
your 20 or 30 doing wga west it's a waste of
time doesn't do any good um it's not going to
do what you want it to do spend the extra 25 and
do it with the usco the u.s library of congress
u.s copyright office is what that
stands for the process is just as easy
the copyrights last forever not five years
copyrights cover your legal expenses to defend
the fact that you got ripped off and as we're
young and naive coming up in hollywood we tend to
really love to share our work with people and i
always tell people don't you dare send a script
to anybody until it's finished and copy written
because it's too easy the person you're sending
it you could steal it the person that you sent it
to could send it to a friend who needs an idea or
hey i'm thinking about getting into screenwriting
do you have any scripts laying around i can look
at and kind of use as a model the easiest thing
to do for a new writer is to look at somebody
else's work and just copy it what happens i've
been ripped off over the years i actually had a
script get produced by a studio who i'll not
name they actually went out made the movie it
was a 9 million dollar indie low budget film that
they they put the money behind to make and they
were dumb enough not to even change the title
of the film or the character names so i guess
whoever brought it to them took my work and
just put their name on a cover sheet and just
did it as is i gotten wind of this when they
were in post and what you're supposed to do
when you get ripped off is you let the film come
out like let it get on the books and let the
trailers start hitting and then that that monday
before the friday is when you drop your bomb
because they are so vested in this with the 20
million in p a or whatever it is they're gonna
work out a deal with you and instead stupid here
knew somebody who knew somebody who worked at the
studio when i heard it was in post-production
i made noise about it and then the film just
disappeared it never came out it was never
finished but they indeed um my friend got
me a copy of the script there was a polish on the
script but they kept the names the same they kept
the title the same i go on imdb it's still there
unreleased 15 years later but uh it's just kind
of funny this movie got made that never never even
got finished no release so that was one i've had
agencies uh take projects and give them
to show runners days after we meet on them
sometimes hours after i've had a project that
was packaged by a major agency and an 07 when the
crash hit my investors backed out we were three
weeks away from rolling film and you know when the
the 07 recession hit my investors had to back out
so the project never got made and then weirdly
enough two years later the packaging agent got a
new client who shot pretty much the same script
wound up making it into sundance and doing
quite well and at least they changed the title
they changed the character names and the best
part was they changed the opening scene but the
rest of the movie was pretty much in step so you
know i don't make noise about that stuff anymore
i've learned and that's probably why
i become an independent filmmaker
if i have an idea i'm passionate about i'm not
sending it to you i'm just going to go make it
that's where i've gotten is i just don't share
my work with anybody if something i believe in
and want to do it stays in-house and we'll do
it so that's usually how a lot of people do it
if they feel their ideas been stolen they wait
till the week of well you'll often hear about a
film that comes out and you'll hear writers are
making noise they said their idea was taken and
that's usually when the film is coming out and
what happens is you get the studio or the network
so vested in the project they've completely paid
the entire process now they're going through the
marketing and pa and they've committed a
good year a year and a half to the project
and then all of a sudden it's coming out and you
know it's not common but it's not rare where you
hear this movie's coming out and there's a couple
of writers who say that they were ripped off and
more often than not those stories disappear and
go away and i think if you're able to prove it
i always say you know you have to take copious
notes i always say i have a backup email address
so anytime you send a script to somebody
send it to another address you have and
keep those things print them out save them on
a cloud so you have a track record if you send
a script to somebody you have a conversation with
somebody keep a journal hey i spoke to this agent
at this agency on this day about this actor
and this project because you know it's just
if you're gonna ever make noise that you were
ripped off you have to have you have to have
chapter and verse copious notes on everything
that that you've done or there's just no
you know ideas don't cut in anymore you
have to show that there was an interaction
well it's kind of like the guys that pointed
the finger at zuckenberg for ripping off
facebook i mean they still probably got
two three four hundred million dollars
it was an undisclosed settlement but they were
able to prove this guy took their platform and did
something else with it and that you have to think
of it the same way you have to have the blueprints
for your work you have to have detailed journal
you have to have your communications and when
they were what they were and who they were with so
yeah and copyrighted with the library of congress
so was that is that true that it's easier for
hollywood to just deal with the lawsuit than pay
i think everybody likes dealing with a lawsuit
than going through the the painstaking uh it
seems everybody today wants the easy way out uh
it's easy to rip off things it's too easy to take
advantage i know a very prominent producer who
since passed away so i'm gonna tell the story
without mentioning a name you know he found a
script he was he was a very successful producer
and he had been nominated for an oscar 3
and found a script from an unknown writer
who wasn't in a wga or anything and basically
worked out a deal to pay the guy peanuts and
wound up becoming a very successful trilogy and
you know just bought and sold the script over and
over until he got it where it needed to go and you
know it's it just seems like hollywood's kind of
copying itself anyway i mean that's what it does
right every story has been told it's how we tell
it you know shark movies are big right now let's
make a shark movie football movies are big right
now let's do a football movie i mean you know i
we capitalized on that with great iron gang you
know we had we are marshall yet invincible
yet we are giants we're facing the giants
yeah friday night lights it started it so
you had this movement of football movies
and it's no different i mean that's just what they
do incidentally what's interesting is the same guy
who took that script for peanuts it turned out
admitted to me later he was trying to make red
iron gang with another studio and he never had the
rights to do it so it goes to show you you know
it's people will just easily take an idea and run
with it and yeah he never had the rights to do it
you know how do you feel when somebody rips
off your work it's i guess the old saying is
imitation is the greatest form of flattery but
when you're reading the front page of the trades
and a big star is attached to a project that
you walked into an agency or a network you know
my dad always talks about how he had brought in
a uh a script back in the in the early 70s called
special weapons assault tactics and was told
that's not for us and then you know years later
so i uh i learned you know be careful with your
product but how does it feel when you're ripped
off it it it hurts because you have that it's
almost you know it's like if you've ever walked
into your house after it's been robbed it's the
ultimate it's the ultimate betrayal it's the
ultimate form of of uh you know it's a violation
i don't know why somebody can't just say hey
kid you wrote a script it's pretty good the idea
is there we want to take it and work we're going
to pay you i mean just the deception that happens
with these things and i i can't emphasize enough
that you have to i mean it's it feels empty you
look at that time and you most writers especially
write things on spec because one day wouldn't
it be great and then one day you have a library
of scripts that you can look back and say you
have these 10 scripts but each script takes time
whether you're a fast writer or slow writer i know
people that spend three months on a screenplay
i know people spend 10 years on a screenplay
i know somebody's actually under 30th year on
the same script i cannot imagine if that got
ripped off i mean 30 years think about it so
i tend to take things well that i tend to take bad
news well so i didn't get all wrapped up in it i
just okay lesson learned chalk it up as a life
lesson and move on did you get any compensation
for a chain i never got compensated there are
three projects that i did that i created that got
taken um one was produced into a film that
never came out the other one went into pretty
hardcore development at a major network with
a big star attached it never never did come
um there was another one that it was basically we
had a pretty good timeline and proof that there
was there was a ripoff um and what was interesting
is the the the institution the studio whatever you
want to call it that did the ripping off had also
optioned another project from us previously so
what they basically did is they took intellectual
property that they had optioned from us
and put it into another project a storyline
into another project that they already greenlit
totally separate they were going to make
that anyway they were hoping to make ours
ours didn't really come to fruition so they
kind of grabbed some stuff and threw it in there
we hired the best of the best lawyers and they
were unbelievable in how they structured this
case and their timelines and at the end of
the day nobody wants to go to court nobody
wants to sue anybody i'm a firm believer
in the blacklist i know people and i don't
mean the script side i'm talking about people
saying we're not going to work with him because
and it just got to a point where you know other
deals other options were made hey you know so do
you get paid for it no sometimes if it's handled
in a certain way and i think right you could
possibly uh you could you could entertain another
deal or two with with a with an an institution
that would admit maybe they wronged you or were
upset you felt wronged you know optioning another
piece of property for two or three years isn't
uncommon i guess if you play your cards right
basically what happened is they just said look
you know all right we did what we did and you guys
want to go through a lot we're going to bankrupt
you in lawsuits it's going to take 12 years today
do you have something else we can option and
you know they're not going to make it but you
know but that's how they do it i mean that's
how that's how it worked on the third on the
first on the studio one yeah yeah they you know
they'll come up with creative ways to make you
feel or hey why don't we give you a development
deal no not to pay anything they just take a few
gratuitous meetings with you over the course of
two years and you feel like you got yours you know
interesting it's it's weird you know it's it's
a deceptive business and i think that's what's
driven me i'm i don't i don't ever want to thumb
my nose at hollywood proper i've had a lot of
success in it and thank god for it and hope to
work again in it i don't count on it and i don't
care if i don't i went real rogue independent
in what i do because i just got tired of dealing
with a machine i got tired of developing you know
fall in love with an idea put it together whether
you've got eight dollars or eight hundred thousand
dollars and go do it what's stopping you you know
i mean the next film i'm doing we're starting in
in a couple months and it it started because a
group of us were sick and tired of sitting around
during covet and we figured we can toss 20 20 in
the garbage bin like a lot of people are or we can
show something we have something to show for it
and it was kind of like we know two guys with
two great cameras and a sound guy we got actors
that want to play i got a great writer who's got
a ton of material i'll direct produce and cut
the thing for free i don't care let's make this
year something and then it turned into something
where investors have gotten involved in better
actors and bigger actors and crew and now all of
a sudden we have a real movie we're gonna go make
and it happened because we just got sick and tired
of sitting around and started putting things
into motion we never asked anybody for money
that was the last thing we just wanted to
get busy and have something to show for 2020.
and the next thing you know we're in
full-blown pre-production on a show
you know so i think i like that there's
no development there's let's do it
but how does a writer protect themselves from
getting taken advantage of even though they
have that they they really want that thing to
pay off for them again i think i think the most
important thing a writer can do is obviously you
have to copyright your material and that includes
the treatments it includes the script and i think
you have to take you have to take notes of where
projects go um you know i look back at some of
the projects i had ripped off and if i had just
taken better notes just documented who what when
where and why i could have stopped them from being
taken or at least gotten to partake in its success
or failure from a producer or creator standpoint
and i just think it's too easy to you know
be people when we're coming up we want
so bad to have our work accepted we want to make
it so bad whether we're an actor or a writer
the problem is if you're an actor and you want to
make it you can audition you can go out and meet
people and do your thing but your only calling
card as a writer is to write and unfortunately
everything starts with the script you don't
have an actor attached you don't have a producer
a director a set financing until what's
the script it's all about the script
so you're kind of kicking off the whole project
and the most valuable thing that somebody can take
is a script it's the only thing they can take they
can't take an actor they can't take a director
they can't steal a craft service person
they're going to steal the script
so you have to really think that you're really the
the lifeblood of a project you are the inception
of the project and what you have is gold to some
people so you have to protect it you have to you
have to take as much time as you've taken to
write your script you have to think i have to
copyright it i have to copyright every bit of
intellectual property that surrounds it whether
it's your beat sheets your breakdown your you
know your boards whatever it is you just you
got to protect everything and then you have to
really really be clear on who you've given it to
why you're giving it to me and i also be careful
what you're giving it to you know hungry writers
i can't tell you how often well this this producer
reached out to me on you know facebook and uh you
know they i sent them three of my scripts i never
heard from them again it's like well okay did you
look up who the producer was well you know he he
had this ac credit on a film two years ago and
you know look if if a real producer wants to work
with you they're not going to find you on facebook
usually now i understand that as a way to find
people but how did they find you on facebook did
they read something else you wrote and facebook
was the only way to find you or were they just
trolling for people in the writing forums and
the writing you know uh what are they called the
the writing forms of facebook and that's where
a lot of these people get taken advantage of
it's really easy all you have to do is dm
one writer who's writing something on the
board that you think is intelligent gullible
vulnerable and hungry enough and just say hey
uh here's who i am i'm interested in what you got
i'd love to read your work and nine times out of
nine they're probably going to send it you know
screen cap those conversations get this guy's name
look them up start a file on everybody you send
stuff to you should have a file on every project
and a file on everybody who sees whatever project
you have and that's a big way to protect yourself
a dossier is that what that is i've heard
new words that's what the government does
what is there there's the dossier and then
there's the uh what's the other one oped i've
heard these new words since the last four years
i never knew before and in the reverse how can
someone who's been asked to read their script
vet a producer so seeing just like one credit on
imdb with no picture no contact info very little
online presence is that someone who you should
really be sending your work to i i always think
it's important for people to vet on the other
side is is you know we've talked about before the
easiest thing to do if you're a person who has a
business card that says you're a producer but you
haven't physically produced uh the easiest thing
to do is go to something like facebook and find
a writer's form and find people that are you know
all you have to do is join it's free to join
and you get to see the trends and habits and
some of the idiosyncrasies of the people that
are on that site and you start realizing their
vulnerabilities their hopes their fears their
concerns and where they are careless i find it
amazing that people will actually say here's my
latest script and throw it on a facebook forum
and you go oh my god or a guy will say hey i just
did these 10 pages last night would love feedback
okay um you know i think that's careless um but
you know producers are predatory by nature and
sorry but they are that you have something they
want so i think you need to protect your work
i think you need to think twice before you just
shotgun your material out i think you need to look
up people i still there's a lot of writers that i
respect that i know and i still try to collaborate
with that'll say oh i heard from a producer i
sent this guy my work he reached out to me and i'm
looking i'm gonna go have you even oh no i know he
doesn't have an imdb presence or he doesn't even
have but he's you know and it's like not that imdb
is the end-all be-all but good lord if somebody
has got a history in the business of being
legitimate that's certainly one way to better them
and i just it's mind-boggling how how often people
don't uh take the time they don't want to hear the
truth so they just they just shotgun it hoping
that this could be the one and i think they
have to be very careful hence you know getting
your your projects ripped off several times of
your career because you're not you know careful
and i gave my projects to people that were real
and legit but i didn't protect myself and they
know when you don't so even if someone's vetted
doesn't necessarily mean that you're safe just
because somebody's vetted doesn't mean that
you're safe i mean you know easiest thing to
do is to get a script that's not copy written
then have the power to make something and get it
from somebody who has no cloud or juice or voice
or word uh in the industry and if that's the case
then what what do they have to stand on if they're
not protected you know so what if someone says
well then maybe i just shouldn't trust anybody
then why even then why even bother doing this
well you shouldn't you shouldn't trust don't trust
anybody what you should do is protect your work
as we talked about before with the you know united
states copyright office don't waste your time with
the wga do it with the usco it's the same process
kind of costs a little bit more but it's it shows
people that are in the know that you're serious
it shows that you know how to protect your
work and take copious notes and you should
have a file on each project and you should
have a file on everybody that you send it to
that should be part of it and those
correspondences and if it's a phone call
take notes i talked to shane stanley today
it's october 1st 2020. he said he wanted
me to send a synopsis emailed shane stanley at
this email address the synopsis for this story
waiting for a call back or a phone you know an
email and then when i email her phone back print
it out put it in the file and that way if i go
off and make that movie i've got it it's now the
burden of proof is on me that i didn't rip them
off it's always on the rider to prove that i that
i ripped you off but now all of a sudden if you do
your due diligence it's now on me to show that i
have to now provide all the stuff that i did to
develop the material and that's harder to do do
you do this like in excel or award pages what i
usually do is i have a backup email address like
if i have my company account whatever it is dot
com i have a yahoo account that i don't access or
give out to anybody all it is is my overages it's
every time i email a project to somebody i bcc
it and then that way i have it safe and then when
that person replies i have a folder on my main
of each project so every time i get a hit so
i'm getting i got the send out sent somewhere
else and then i've got the reply and a whole
different other email mask so that way god
forbid one crashes one goes blank or gets hacked
i at least have half the conversation somewhere
that's how i do it that's great we've imagined
that you've received your share of screenplay
pitches or you've heard about others pitching
what are some of the wrong ways to pitch what
are some of the wrong ways to reach out to someone
i think there is a right way and a wrong way to
present people your work your screenplays to
approach them i think if you break it down
i think writers need to be just as good if not
better as writing a synopsis or a treatment i
like getting those two page treatments where you
know if it's five acts it's a paragraph per act
a title a log line a brief synopsis and then
the breakdown i think if you can do that and
you can basically summarize what it is you're
trying to say i get i can tell in two minutes
that this is a story i want to read i don't need
to see a script but it's really important that
you know the craft of of writing too because uh
writing is a gift writing is a craft and a lot of
people don't understand the importance of good
storytelling and because they've spent a year
and a half writing a script doesn't mean it's
good and they have to respect a lot of people
get hit with so many scripts that they take it
personally if you don't want to read it and you
know we all have lives we're busy we have business
life personal life social life we have all these
things in our own work life and i always you
know if somebody is kind considerate and they
reach out i always try to say okay i won't look
at a synopsis but only if it's copy written i
need to see the copyright you know registration
receipt i'm not i don't take anything without that
um so make sure you have your work copy written
and be kind and considerate and realizing that
you're you know you're you're not the only person
who has a script that needs red and reading a
script does take people a couple of hours out of
their day and you know how many people do you know
that you don't know that would take two hours out
of the day for a stranger to just read your script
so i just think it's about the presentation
it's about knowing how to write a synopsis or
a treatment that can lure a reader or a decision
maker to want to know more about what you're doing
is really important how often do you receive
cold pitches uh you know it's not that often
um i get i mean i get a lot of inquiries which
i really appreciate i don't mind people asking
i'm an open book you know anybody can email me
info chainstanley.net i mean i don't care it's
how it's done and it's for me um when i just
get an email that's shotgun and i know it's
shocked i even look at it i just you know
i just write back and say i don't accept
unsolicited material and i cc my lawyer i cc
my manager and i write them back and i say hey
you know you sent this to me unsolicited i am not
interested in seeing this this is not how to do it
appreciate it if you have somebody who who reps
you if they want to reach out to my manager or
lawyer that's a different story and i never hear
back from them again that's just the end of it
people who reach out genuinely you know because
i do so much work with the colleges that you know
i'll encounter a writer three years ago and then
they'll write you know and say you know dear shane
you gave a workshop at my class in florida a few
years ago and you know i finished a screenplay
and i really enjoyed your may i send it to you
i always write back and say i'm not going to
read your screenplay right now but if you want to
send me you know copyright everything i go through
copyright everything i need to see that it's been
registered certified copywritten with the usco
once that's done i will gladly look at a treatment
and we can go from there and usually they're
pretty cool about it i don't mind reading those
i don't i'm not going to read scripts i just
don't have the time and i know that's terribly
heady to say but i just don't i'm a slow reader
shane what are the top five reasons you
will reject a screenplay let's say it's
it's well written it's formatted but there's
just something that's not working for you
you know when rejecting a screenplay the first
thing writers should never take it personally
art is nothing but opinion i mean you think
about how many great scripts got made years
after the fact after they were turned down
and rejected by so many other filmmakers
it's about first and foremost it's about the
project connecting with the person you're
sending it to just because i made a movie about
football and had success with it doesn't mean i
want to make another movie about football i also
want to evolve as a filmmaker so what's important
is is that you never take it personally um i
would hope if i do read a script and i think
there's something there that i would at least
write i would always try to make it a point to
write the writer or contact the writer and say
look i gotta be honest with you you're talented
i like what you're doing i know somebody who
i think would appreciate it let me help you
you know i have no problem with that and
one of the writers that i work with who i
use one of my favorites to work with is cj
wally he's the the guy that has group revolution
out of the uk and our relationship kicked
off by reading one of his scripts that was
beautifully done i would never make the movie
i couldn't sell the movie but it didn't mean he
can't write and i i read his words i read his the
his setups i read his you know his character arcs
and i just and i read his theory on breaking
down scripts and doing proper treatments and
synopses and i this guy had it all together and
for me it was like hey dude i love your writing
i have a project i'm gonna do i want you to write
it and then we were able to work together and like
you know we've written several scripts together
and that came because i read a script that i i
would never make but i knew the writer was good
so it's not always about the script i don't think
spec scripts get made much anymore filmmakers have
an idea what they want we have actors that we know
what they want to do we have buyers and sales
agents who we know what they can sell at the
moment and we have an audience trend that you know
right now doing a drama living in an apartment
is not going to sell we have all been locked in
because of covid for six months in our four walls
we want to be outside we want to laugh i don't
want to hear about your problems i don't want
to think about my problems so if we're selling
scripts right now and you're trying to pitch it
better be adventure it better be funny it better
have romance it better get me out on the water i
want it to get me out in the desert i want to go
on travel these are the things that you constantly
have to think about and writers don't writers are
very myopic and that's okay we we get in a box
and it's all about this and you have to realize
there's there's actors there's money that has to
be raised there's directors that have to come
on board there's um teams of people that have
to capture the vision to make this happen and
after all that's said and done is can it be sold
are there those seven trailer moments in
this script that we know we can sell it
is there an uh an output worldwide or is this just
gonna appeal to one place and that's these are
the things that a lot of writers don't think about
the business of the business it's not just whether
your script is good so much of it is about where
is it going to sell you're still selling a widget
are you selling a widget that only appeals to
one out of every 5 000 people or are you selling
a widget that everybody kind of needs and that's
how you have to look at it when making a script
and what are those seven trailer moments
i don't think they're anything specific i
think they're the catch phrases they're those
hero moments if you're telling an actions right
like you take any two-minute super trailer
that you see and you'll see those five to nine
moments that you know are important in the film
they're the the tent poles of the story they're
the catch phrases they're that huge explosion
they're that great moment in the car chase
it's it's the sex scene real quick it's
the action running it's it's those things
and they're not anything consistent but
your story has got to be able to tell
the executives who don't read scripts and don't
know much it's got to tell them that i can sell
this that's all it is it's can i sell it some
of the relationships i have with sales agents
and buyers they don't read the scripts they want
the synopsis they want mock art you know they
want to see a mock poster that me and a writer
make and in two hours on photoshop and say here
here's your kind of idea for the image here's
your here's your log line here's your title
and they'll tell you right then and there yeah i
can sell that that's how these decisions are made
wow so so what why not even forget the treatment
why not just come up with a great poster and log
well i think that's but you still have to have a
script to shoot and finance so ultimately you're
going to need the script um but i think i think
that's all part of the package because so many
people are from the filmmaker side i don't write
as much but if i have a writer who's done a script
i expect the synopsis and the treatment to be as
good if not better than the script it's got to be
because i know there's there's always
three scripts the one you write the one
you shoot and the one you cut okay the
treatment is what you're really selling
overall they executives are not going to read the
script i deal with more executives now they just
want to see they just want a two-page synopsis
and just show me some mock art so i know what
i'm selling and they'll tell you well tell me
in five minutes i can sell it or you're gonna
find somebody else i can't do anything with this
it's not my wheelhouse okay and then we make the
decision do we do we believe in this enough to
roll the dice and struggle and pull teeth and
try to get it somewhere else or do we listen to
people we trust and say this is not the one to do
that's our developmental process it's very quick
we don't go through the years of development or
months it's here's an idea i'll pitch the idea to
my buyers if they like it i say okay they like it
let's do the synopsis and then i get them the
synopsis sometimes with some mock art and then
they'll either say okay the idea is good act
two i can't you can't do this in act two this
this i can't sell tweak it this way and then
they'll go you know in act four can this happen
maybe in act five it's happening too soon or can
you bring the villain in sooner those are the
kind of conversations we have and then it just
the table is set and the writer can go do it
and i the script the spec script is very hard
to sell i think spec scripts are great calling
cards if somebody can write or not found
a tremendous writer through the community
college just this during covid who i take a
lot of pride in i not only got her a manager
she got a job like writing a script for hire
for a very substantial production company and
this is one of my zoom students from the
community colleges that reached out to me
you were asking the right way and wrong way she
reached out to me she had taken three or four of
my zoom classes with a community college lovely
woman very articulate kind no expectations just i
really appreciate it i would love to share my work
with you here's where i want to go in my career
and she's she's an older woman she's like you know
her son's like my age i mean she's been around
and has worked around the industry but never
really flourished as a writer and i finally
said let me know when you're synonymous oh my god
i know somebody who's looking for this so i said
i'm not going to read your script send it to
me i'll send it to somebody who knows this
company and the guy read the script called me
up and goes who is this woman she's really good
and we got her an agent and three weeks later
she actually got a work for hire on a greenlit
film that they green they had greenlit on
the concept and they liked her writing enough
to say you were you were a writer for hire
on this and she's on her last she's on her
second polish on it and they're getting ready
to go into production i think in january
it's greenland how common is that not very but
i say that to inspire because there are ways
and again it came from being kind it came from
being a familiar face it came from somebody who
who reached out with a tender heart and a gracious
heart to understand and respect my schedule and
maybe i didn't want to read it and understood when
i said i don't want to read your script but let me
let me look at the synopsis and then when i was
like there's something here i said i'm going to
send a synopsis to somebody i think would like
this and if they do i'm going to need you to have
a script ready and that's how it went is synopsis
king in this day and age of instant information
and being able to get answers quickly i suggest
that it is definitely something that is put to the
forefront uh going back to people's time and you
know we've developed this instant gratification
generation of you know getting it on the phone
and i'll get you an answer let me ask siri
i think a lot of us have put that into our
workflow um i know what my days are i i hit
the ground i am working by 5 5 30 in the morning
even when i'm not making a movie and my wife
is usually saying all right honey come on it's
getting late you've been you know this is when
we're not doing a movie i just i'm immersed in my
work so taking two hours a day to read a script
it doesn't fit i don't schedule read days so
my my feelings if you want to write and you
want to get seen by filmmakers who are busy and i
suggest you really learn how to build a treatment
besides being a good screenwriter learn how
to do a treatment learn how to do a synopsis
um there is a a web platform based in the united
kingdom called script revolution it was it was
it was created by cj wally and i find if you're a
writer i suggest you go and check out it's a free
site it's it's it's i think you will be blown
away on the the way it breaks down how to write
not only screenplay but the treatment the synopsis
the act breakdowns he's created some you know the
turn and burn which is this really cool theory
and i think once you understand that as a writer
your treatments are gonna flourish which are
going to make people that are in a position of
making movies get more excited about what it is
you're doing and what you're trying to say so
i think the treatment and the synopsis
is so important the script ultimately is
but if i read a great synopsis and a great
treatment i will be more forgiving on the script
knowing where ultimately this could go where
if i just get a mediocre script and it's
okay and done i don't see the vision that
you caught me in a page or two so i'm a
big proponent for the treatment i'm sorry
just real quickly what is the turn and burn
that's a good question that's for him to answer i
mean if you go if you go on the website if you go
on to scriptrevolution.com there is a whole sub
chapter about turn and burn and it's his theory
on how he creates the synopsis and it's a whole
it's a whole map of like 10 different sayings that
he has that i could never relay i don't write
anymore but it all makes sense and when i know
when i've collaborated with him or other writers
that are part of his platform it's it's really
it's really about the developmenting the treatment
develop the treatment so the script process is
is easy it's like as i talked about in my book
the most important thing about filmmaking is the
pre-production time i i work myself to death
during pre-production so production is fun
and easy that's how it's supposed to be you
know pro football players will tell you you work
monday through saturday and you get paid to play
on sunday that's how it should be when you write
that's how it should be when you make a movie
and what they've done at script revolution is
they have basically given you training camp hell
week and practice in the treatment side so the
writing of the script is actually fast efficient
and it's right on point and there's no surprises
and that's what most filmmakers development
executives get concerned about is writers going
down rabbit holes they weren't supposed to go
down going off track if your treatment is in order
everything is it's expected
you're just filling up the pages
with witty dialogue with fun i'll give
you an example working on this film
we developed we've got a we've got a six page
treatment that's the five acts it's the character
breakdown who everybody is what the point of the
show is what's the log line what's the synopsis
we have gotten four acts in seven days there's not
been one surprise except happy surprises because
we all know where this is there's four of us that
are involved in doing the film that are from a
decision-making capacity not one of us have been
thrown a bump a roadblock a speed bump nobody's
been like oh my god what's going on and it was
because the way the treatment was handled going in
it's it's it is so paramount and speaking
of bumps i don't know if you're reading my
mind but i was just going to bring up goosebumps
it's so funny that was the next thing i was going
to say was that r.l stein i guess the creative
goosebumps he talked about how he knows the ending
and he writes this treatment or whatever and
then once he knows the ending then he can go back
and he can fool the audience and it's it's
effortless writing but it's just getting that
that structure in place and i know
and i know in the way that they
do these treatments they often will have 17 blank
pages and start on page 17 and work backwards
it's not uncommon and it's interesting and
there's different ways for it to work for
everybody but it's kind of just basically a way to
think about it and i think once you capture that
whether you're a writer or not you see what he's
doing oh i get it and too many of us in the way i
used to write when i used to try to hack away was
i would just sit there and come up with a title
and write fade in and tell my story sometimes
i got lucky and sold a few scripts i did okay
but as i got older my mind wasn't as fast i wasn't
as creative i had kind of burned a lot of that
creative energy telling stories and then becoming
a filmmaker an editor a producer or director or i
wasn't just sitting for weeks at a time writing so
i learned later in life how important a treatment
is it's it's so important to know what it is
you're going to do and it's great when you can
surprise yourself as a writer but to know where
you're going to know the purpose of each scene
to know the arcs and the back stories that aren't
going to be on the page of each character i think
if you as a creator know all that you'd be amazed
the stories that you can tell it's just it's just
smooth sailing shane we've heard you say send
us treatment we've heard on our side people say
okay i sent them a treatment it was a 20 page
treatment is that okay is that too long oh i
think in first pass i think i think you need to
again be considerate of the reader when i say send
a treatment i would like a title i'd like to know
who it was written by i'd love to see a log line
and then i'd like to see a two-page synopsis give
me a paragraph per act that's it that's all i need
and i could either say yeah i like this i want
to see a script or i could say you know what if
you have a more in-depth treatment breaking down
some things back story on the characters cast size
i'd love to see it that 20 then i would expect
that 10 to 12 to 20 page treatment it's not that
you shouldn't have them i feel when i say you need
to be versed as a writer in writing synopsises and
treatments those are two separate things that
are equally as important because i'm only going
to read a synopsis first i just want to see a page
or two on what you're doing and if that instills
not quite enough interest to see the script but
i'm intrigued enough to say i want to know more
that's when that 20-page treatment or whatever it
is that you've done is important obviously not a
90-page treatment then just send me the script
but you know what i mean it's it's i think the
synopsis is king it's it's just let's let's ignite
that fire spark the interest and if you get that
have the treatment ready but hopefully the
script is there and tight good that was a
great question because it is because some people
send you like a paragraph you're like that's it
you know i always say here's an option should
just be a paragraph per you know treatment is a
paragraph per act and then the breakdowns anything
but a synopsis should be about a page and a half
two pages and and if you need more than that to
tell the story you gotta you gotta relook at your
story it's too confusing it's too it's too long
it's too you know it's too hodgepodgy you gotta
tighten it up what if someone doesn't know the
difference between a synopsis versus a treatment i
think a synopsis versus a treatment a good answer
at least that that i can give and what i see it as
a synopsis is usually a paragraph or two you know
a thousand words or less is kind of it's going to
tell me what this is now a treatment usually
is going to have a log line it's going to have
what the tonality is it's going to have
the purpose it's going to have the message
and then it's going to give me five acts and it's
a paragraph or if it's three acts it's gonna be a
paragraph per act and then it's gonna talk about
the characters it's gonna break them down as if
you would see in an actor's breakdown it's gonna
say you know uh karen age 25 comes from humble
comes from humble beginnings loves cats it's got
a wonderful husband you know and those are the
kind of things you don't see in a synopsis
as much as you know karen mid 30s oh i just
added 10 years but i think i think a treatment
is more a real breakdown of developmental notes
tonality purpose where this can go and all the
possibilities like one thing that they do in
in what script revolution teaches is um
alternative endings i always like when they break
something down for me and i've got the five acts
i've got the tonality i've got the this and that
and then all of a sudden it says alternative
endings and it says this first what we went
with and then it gives four or five alternative
endings that are completely different that still
fit and why you could or couldn't use them it's
just really to me it's really fleshing out your
story as a writer and giving people different
different perspectives of how it could go you
know we've all heard about alternative endings and
seeing the fun dvd bonuses where this movie had
three different endings like i understand castaway
had three different endings that they shot
well obviously those were written and that was an
option it was something that was on the table well
the writer gave that gift to the filmmakers and
the filmmakers ultimately decided to go with the
one where he's at four corners and the welder who
he left the package for came up and told him which
way to go and she just went and we never know
if he followed her or not but there were three
endings apparently and i'm sure that the treatment
probably talked about those opportunities
do you think you've run out of ideas you said
just you know as time's gone on just you've told
so many stories and you've made so many films and
things do you think someone runs out of ideas oh
i don't think i would i would hate to think
people run out of ideas if you have found a niche
and you flourished in a niche and done the same
style over and over and over again i think you
got to be careful not to try to become a
one-trick pony um i've done different kind
of films in my career i've done the dramas
i've done the rom-coms i've done the actions
i've done the thrillers i've done the suspense
i've done you know i enjoy the action thrillers
a little bit more as i get older i'm gearing more
toward doing those especially the female driven
action film is really where i'm focusing the next
chapter of my life um adventure romance you know
adventure romance stories are fun too um i think
what's important is to collaborate with people
that inspire you um i don't write anymore but i
know i'm good at ideas and i know that from the
writers that i collaborate with they said oh no
you've given me something i can run with this and
that's all i'm responsible of is all i can say is
hey here's some here's a story i want to tell does
that do anything for you and they either catch the
vision or they don't um i think every story has
been told it's how we tell it that makes it fresh
right i mean you know everybody's seen mob movies
everybody's seen action movies everybody seen
you know the harry met sally knock-offs and the
scream knock-offs i mean it's all been done what
what twist are you gonna put in there what what
originality or flair are you gonna what wrinkle
are you gonna put in the story that's gonna make
audiences engage and not feel that they've seen
this over and over again i think that's important
when you start thinking about the structure of a
story key beats turning points you know i think um
i think you need to keep a reader
engaged i don't think there is a set
time but if you're you know 15 18 20 25 30 pages
in and we still have no idea what's going on
or there hasn't been that you know moment i i
think you kind of need to rethink some things um
you know there's the old saying when you watch a
movie it's that 42 to 46 minute point that usually
kind of becomes a slow burn no matter what the
movie is so i know a lot of writers and filmmakers
try to make sure that point of the film doesn't
lack a spark or an interest because that's a lot
of times where people they're not going to give up
on the film but they tend to get a little restless
it seems a lot of people take a really long time
to get to the point and i think and i've learned
that as a independent filmmaker when you sell
your material it's more about you know we have
to remember this as a business and now in days
with phones and tablets and distractions and
pets and kids and everything else under the sun
going on we're constantly interrupted audiences
when they see your film unless they're really at a
movie theater and truly turn their phones off are
never really 100 immersed in your story there's
always something there's a noise outside there's
a cat knocking over a vase it's a kid who's crying
because he didn't get his way and he's hungry and
you know you have to realize that as a
filmmaker what you're up against and i think
to just kind of lull along to tell your
story it's very rare that you're going to
be able to compete with anything so i think
to be able to throw some twists and turns
to engage your audience into some new layers or
elements or characters or what's the point of this
movie a little sooner than we used to i think
is happening needs to happen more often and i
think a lot of writers are starting to figure
that out so then you wouldn't be working some
of this out in the treatment stage it's once you
actually start the actual screenwriting process
i've gotten to the point now when i work with
writers i tell them it's got a you know it's
it's sadly um there's kind of an 11-minute rule
abroad that we kind of need to know what this
is about what's going on what we're signing up
for in the first 11 minutes of the actual movie
which is going to tell somebody that's got to
happen in the first 12 to 15 pages of the script
um and i don't like telling stories that way but
i've also learned the hard way i've had some some
projects that you know hey if you do this it'll
sell hey if you change this it will it will move
and what i've learned is the faster we get to the
point in our storytelling and i know this goes
against everything from telling great stories of
the old days but we're living in a new time and it
has really gotten to be about get to the freaking
point what am i signing up for early they they
want to know it's like you know give an example in
the film that i just did that's coming out break
even it's about four kids who find 50 million
dollars while scuba diving at a remote island and
we developed this opening and this whole thing and
this back story and why are these kids here and
who are they and what's their relationships and it
was basically yeah we need to find out 50 million
dollars by 12 minutes in it's like well wait a
minute that doesn't come in until page 30. well
it needs to come in about 12 minutes in so you
you have to restructure some things you have to
cut scenes you have to cut backstory because at
the end of the day when you're selling a movie
around the world they're signing up for something
and if you're selling an action film if you're
selling a thriller if you're selling a suspense
story you better get to it because there's too
much competition there's too many things that
are moving fast that'll hold the tension because
it moves so fast that's where that mtv generation
of cutting came from is we don't know how to tell
a good story so we're gonna cut a bunch of stuff
really fast so you're afraid to take your eyes off
the screen and that has now become it's found its
way i think it's found a balance in storytelling
with films a little better but we need to get
to the point and if you look at the older films
uh some of the most of the ones that i grew up
you know cherry it's a fire the black stallion
you know all these enchanting april you're
looking like 25 28 35 minutes in until you
really kind of have an idea if you watch
the black stallion they don't in introduce
mickey mickey rooney's character until about i
think 48 minutes in you know the kids alone at
the island for 30 minutes are crying out loud then
he gets home and he's got to reintegrate in school
and then all of a sudden the horse runs away and
then he goes on this trip to try to find the horse
and then there's your co-star and it was also
that way with on golden pond they didn't bring
you know jane fonda in until 25 minutes in
so i don't think those play as much anymore
not saying the films don't hold up is great cinema
but we want to meet the players we want to know
what the game is a lot quicker now or even the
stepford wives like i mean that was like the
original the original one yeah i mean just long
driving scenes with the music the soundtrack and
yeah there was something comforting about that i
don't know if that would work today well you know
quentin did it in once upon a time in hollywood
i think he really exploited the driving scenes
but we're looking at the back of brad pitt and
leonardo dicaprio's head so you know that makes
it a little different but what i try to tell the
independent filmmakers if you're not getting brad
or leo as your stars and i don't even get them
as my stars um your your international buyers
want to get to the point and we're at a point now
where we you know we are able to lock picture and
we don't make different cuts for different markets
or parts of the globe we've kind of learned that
what what works comfortably everywhere you know
there's 54 territories that we sell to around the
globe 100 what is it 170 countries and in that you
you have 54 territories and you want to try to do
something that's going to appeal to everybody and
it's hard to please all the people all the time
but getting to the point quickly is one that you
can really help sell that movie a lot better if
people know what they're signing up for in the
first 15 20 minutes tops well it's interesting
because people seem to get upset when we say that
or we interview people and they say you know if a
script isn't good by 10 pages in most people will
stop reading it and so then the comments are well
you're not giving it a chance right people just
don't have the patience anymore you know again
i hate to revert to it you go back to i mean
look at close encounters of the third kind
brilliant film that is a slow burn i think if that
movie was made today that would be a lot different
not taking anything away from steven who did
a great job writing the script it was based
on an experience he had as a kid and a great
job directing it but you're going to tell me
that movie today would play at that pace i don't
think so and you're right a lot of people you're
not giving it a chance and most readers will say
god if it doesn't get me by page eight i'm done
i think you kind of have to you know the
executives you know there was a trend where
all the executives are saying you got to find that
hook it's got to be edgy you know i want it to be
edgy and grab me you know shake me by my by my
lapels by page eight you know and so everybody
came up with the edgy crazy opening that just
shocked everybody i don't think i don't think
shock and awe is what make people watch a whole
movie people want to be drawn in they want to
care about characters they want to go along for
a journey and they know what they're signing up
for but you have to make that journey interesting
you want to put some bends in the road you want
to have some interesting things that they're going
to pass and i think you need to occasionally give
them a flat tire throw a rod in the engine
they're going to have to get out grab their
bags hitchhike find a ride you know i think i just
think that's where we are now people are just so
bored i mean you look at twitter twitter has
an auto feed now i don't even i can't even go
on it anymore because the second i try to read
what somebody tweeted it automatically scrolls
and i can't find the tweet i was reading and
there's no way to stop that that's just how
we're getting our information now and there's we
gotta find a balance in storytelling but that is
kind of what what's working right now and it's
frustrating it's a hard pace to keep up with
how do you write good dialogue i think the
best dialogue comes from the best listeners
i had an absolute crash course in writing dialogue
years ago i used to write with charlie sheen
i don't care if they don't credit him and the
sitcoms he's been in as a writer i know who's been
writing the dialogue i worked with him for three
years i i never read or heard better dialogue from
anybody than that came from him that he wrote and
i asked him one day i used to be really good at
writing scene direction my dialogue was flat it
wasn't interesting it wasn't engaging it was an
edgy or seat and i asked him one day when we were
writing the way we worked is we'd set it up and i
would write the scene direction and he would do
the dialogue unless you know it was some basic
stuff it was easy and i finally said to him i said
where do you get this encyclopedia of incredible
dialogue i've never heard anybody with it before
and he said you just listen he said you know
when this was working these aren't working and
if these aren't working you can't absorb what's
happening and how people interact and find those
gems he said most most of the things that i write
that people like i heard at a party i heard at
a barbecue i heard at an airport i heard while
i was pumping gas he said you know i'll get out
and pump gas and i'll hear a couple bickering in
the car next to me at the pump and he said that's
gold he goes that is gold man he said you know
and this is before everybody had phones we were
we weren't listening to them we were doing this
so i find the best the best advice to
writing a dialogue is listen put yourself
in a character's position that you've created
you know it goes back to the old um i think
keeping an audience interested in good dialogue i
think also the problem is a lot of people try to
outwit themselves with dialogue they think they've
got to use verbage or words that people don't use
they got to show you how smart they are i think
we've talked about it before it's like the drummer
that overplays everything to show look how good my
chops are and it's not about that it's it's about
it's about making things sound organic and that's
a lot of things that the actors have to understand
too is you know they're acting or are they
truly listening and responding with the work
but i think the best dialogue comes from the
best listeners and the people that know how to
implement those words that they've discovered over
the years and new in new arenas i mean obviously
you're not going to be pumping gas at a gas
station and you're a husband and wife every script
you write is not going to be about a husband and
wife pumping gas at a gas station so where else
can you implement that could that be a film like
sahara where matthew mcconaughey and penelope cruz
are walking across the desert or you can put some
of that bickering in different situations but it's
how you use it how it inspires you to go down
different paths that's how i've i i learned
from him to to write better dialogue i'm still not
very good but i know i i know good dialogue when i
hear it and i'm good at adjusting dialogue when i
get it and i it's about listening and now people
are on phones so you can just hear one side or one
side and i don't think people realize or they care
how well you can hear them and how dialed in
everybody no pun intended to the people are
to what i mean i've heard some major arguments
major personal and i'm like i don't think this
person realizes i can hear them halfway across
the store but that's gold too it's gold and it's
even better when they're when they're on speaker
phone so you do get to hear all of it or they're
the receivers up so loud but you're right i mean
sometimes you'll hear one half of the conversation
and sometimes that could be better because you're
able to imagine i mean can you imagine if it was
hey harold you didn't take the trash barrels in
and that's what the whole fight's about but you're
only hearing harold's side can you imagine what
you can create mod is yelling to him about i mean
when you were working at the car lot did it did
you pick up anything about dialogue i realized
that's not why you were there but if i'm coming
to look at a car you know i'm probably going to
be hesitant i'm probably going to be like i don't
want this guy to sell me anything but i do need
a car but i don't want to let him know that sure
so i'm going to be very selective with what i say
i learned as i said when the owner of galpin
had said come sell cars he said you'll learn
more about life than you've ever known and it'll
be the education that you lacked he wasn't he
wasn't kidding you become a good listener because
you have to overcome all objectives you have to
address every concern and need that a customer has
so how does that happen it happens by listening
and i always i it wasn't dialogue lines i don't
think and i have a very retentive memory if i hear
something i remember it um there wasn't anything
said in those 18 months i worked there that stood
out but it was mannerisms it was quirks it was
character flaws or or neat things about people
that i that i still to this day will implement
in my characters the way a husband and wife
interact it's not about what's said it's about
how it's said it's about the posture it's about um
the the 45 year old son who's with the 70
year old parents buying the ford taurus today
and you realize the parents have a gambling
addiction they're getting a car to drive to vegas
every other week but the 45 year old son
still lives at home to help supplement the
the overhead so they can afford to maintain their
lifestyle and the kids kind of a deadbeat too
i mean there's all sorts of and then you look
at that and you go well that's that's a story
you know you got this retired this retired milk
man and his wife who ran a salon and now they
are addicted to going to vegas every well what
else are they doing when they go to vegas that
we don't know about you know and then your minds
are what do they see on that trip to vegas um
you know it's the the lotto winners i sold i
sold to a few lotto winners that was interesting
i actually had a salesman i worked with who
had won 24 million dollars in the big lotto
and he left his wife and two and a half years
later he was at the point selling cars with me
and you want to talk about like having it all
and losing it and you know friends who abandoned
him when the money was gone and he said yeah you
know it's funny my wife still has her 10 million
you know and here i am selling cars trying
to make trying to make a living living in a
one-bedroom apartment you know and he was the
one who left her and was horrible to her yeah
you see a whole bunch of really interesting um
but that two years sorry to interrupt but that
two years was probably very fascinating
it was fascinating as i said i'm still
very close to the family that that gifted me that
opportunity the bachmanns i am still very close to
some of the salesmen that i worked with a lot you
know sadly some of them have perished um you know
some of the people that were in that sales class
i took patrick wellman just died six months ago i
found out and stuart sank who sold with me and i
got the most character stories out of the anybody
in the world passed uh these would be who i worked
with and i i was very close to and um it was
amazing uh just the people the experiences the the
encounters of just walking out having a cigarette
and encountering a guy whose car is in for an oil
change and that 20-minute exchange you have with
this guy those conversations will live with you
forever but you don't have to sell cars to do it
you can you can drive an uber you can work at
a restaurant as a waiter you can work anywhere
most of the encounters that i've had
in my life that i write about are about
personal experiences or exchanges or encounters
that i've had anywhere but it's funny you bring
up the car years because that was my job
five six days a week i'd spent those eight
to twelve hours a day at the dealership
dealing with no two days were ever the same
fighting between you know salesmen for a customer
or customer you know there's an old saying and
buying cars is all buyers are liars and it
was about trying to i learned something um
we used to have a salesman there that sold ungodly
amounts of cars and made ungodly amounts of money
and i used to say to him what's your secret and he
says you just got to remember all buyers are liars
and they're telling you one thing because
they think they can have an edge and the
secret to successfully selling cars is giving
buyers they got to trust you they got to like
you and want to deal with you but he said
you have to let them think they have control
but they really don't have an ounce of it
and it's almost like being a film director
actors love to be directed and controlled but
they also like to think that they they're the show
they're and as a good director will help steer
them and let them think that they can run with it
and you got to be able to rein them in without
them knowing you're being reined in it's an art
it's a dance and it's that way selling cars um
but it taught me how to negotiate selling cars and
negotiating four five six times a day sure taught
me how to go out and raise money sure taught me
how to negotiate with contracts and actors and
agents it's the same thing how much for how much
right so that's everybody should go sell
cars and you'll become a better filmmaker
what's the best screenplay someone's ever
submitted to you best screenplay somebody's ever
submitted to me wow um i've been fortunate to read
some good ones i mean um you know i got a script
i got a script called chase the sunset from
cj wally years ago that that's what turned
me on to work with him it was just again it
was a film i couldn't really make but it was
just it was just really good and then i was
sent a script by nicole fair fair brother
a while back and it was a love story called the
one and it was just a beautiful pure coming-of-age
story for a married woman who realized she
had she was in a situation that wasn't healthy
it wasn't an abusive relationship it was a
loving marriage it was complacent marriage
but it was a dream of hers to be a writer
and she wanted to put a toe in the water
in the writing world and how her writing was
accepted and the doors that opened to her and it
was told from a woman's point of view it was just
a beautiful story and it was you know occasionally
you find these gems that come your way that you
don't expect they're happy surprises where you
you read it and you say god someday it would be
great to have the power to just give everybody
the middle finger and make it and who cares if
it should or couldn't be done and when i say it
can't be done or i couldn't do it it's because
we have people that we're beholden to that write
checks to make movies they expect films that are
going to be marketed and marketable and going to
work in certain markets that pay a certain amount
and you just know sometimes reading a script
this is not going to work but boy it's you know
sometimes you try to work with the writer and say
can we finagle it a little here and finagle
a little little there and see if we can and
sometimes the writers are so hell-bent on the
vision of the story they say no and they say
i don't care if it never gets made it's going
to stay the way it is or never get made and i
i have a lot of respect for that i really do
um those those two were real special when you
say give the middle finger and i realized you're
just using this metaphor but what does that entail
like what does it really mean are you really are
there people actively stopping the production or
no what it means is is you know i'm very fortunate
i i work with backers who don't read scripts they
don't know or care who's in them they don't ask um
it's usually a synopsis a page a paragraph this is
what it's about here's some teaser artwork
to kind of give you an idea of the world
and we'll usually just photoshop a one sheet
and say this is the idea this is it how much
do you need this much okay and they trust me
and know that this is something that'll sell
around the globe and that they're gonna they're
gonna make their investment back hopefully plus
and it makes sense um when i say give the middle
finger giving the middle finger would be knowing
i'm asking an investor to sign up for something
that the chances are very slim they're going to
see their money back because it's not a marketable
product and also knowing that my sales reps
fortunately we have a good relationship they'll
take it on but i know i've kneecapped them because
i've given them this as a story to sell you know
what i mean there's there's that well you know
okay well you're gonna kill half the territories
are not gonna buy it and instead of getting fifty
thousand dollars for a three-year license in in
spain they're going to give you eight thousand
dollars for five years is that really what
you want well that's not fair to your investor
but hey it's art and you know when i say to give
the middle would be nice to be in a position where
i don't care i'll write the check or i have an
investor we've had so much success they're begging
for a loss maybe this is the one you know and it
does happen it's it's it's hard nobody wants to
go into fail but there are some stories that are
some of the best scripts i've ever written and it
doesn't matter who stars in them or how who does
them you just know that this is not a marketable
product but god it's good it's a story that
needs to be told especially when you come
out of something like cobid we've all we don't
as we talked about we don't want drama right
now dramas are tough cells abroad you know
they're really tough and they're tough anyway
but right now they're extra tough but the
best the best scripts i've written are drama
dramas are tough to sell because of everything
you know we've experienced especially now they're
they're especially they're especially tough but
i'd say the best scripts i've ever read are dramas
would you consider making a feature length
film for ten thousand dollars right now
i've made a feature length film for ten thousand
dollars i've made a a 48-minute pilot for 500
uh budget's never an issue for me um i think we
talked about recently uh coming out of this year
and what a horrible disappointment it's been i
think for everybody um licking our wounds you
know the great losses we've had i think it sadly
started with kobe and then neil pert from rush and
then just went into covet and just crashed and
burned and just kept burning um uh yeah we're
at that point where i think the next one uh just
to keep the risk factor down and just to get out
and shake the dust off i mean we're not going
to spend 10 grand but we're going to keep the
budget low and go out and have some fun i would do
something for 10 grand tomorrow absolutely i would
i hope i elaborate on that and i just it's a
yes or no yeah of course i mean that's where
you know that's where i started you
know my first my first short was
i was told i'd have 25 000 to make it and by
the time we rolled camera i had five grand
you know what happened to the
rest of the money oh you know
[ __ ] you know oh i got 25 grand i'll give you
25 grand let's go make this and well i've got five
okay so is that your litmus if they tell
you to subtract what like 70 percent
i don't work that way anymore i was
young and it was my first directory
director job and you know i had a script and
it was with uh a group of people i wanted to
work with and somebody came to me and said i
want to finance you know one of your projects
and i was like great and they said i'll give
you 25 grand and to me that was a lot of money
i knew what i could do with 25 grand and we we
went the first day and i was told after we were
two hours in oh by the way i was only able to
come up with five grand oh i still gave them the
same film they would have gotten for 25 but you
know i still got an academy award-nominated actor
that's great i did it for five yeah so i'm
all for those no-budget films i love it
what's the lowest budget you would consider i
i never consider a budget i to me look you're
either going to get paid or you're not i don't do
shorts because they take as much time and energy
they just they're just longer on the screen you
still have to pre-produce them you still have to
cast them you still have to hire a crew
you stop feed people you still have to get
locations you still have to put gas in cars so
you know the first the first thing i ever did
i did a 46 minute pilot for 500 bucks and somebody
came to me once and said you did that for 500
it's 48 minutes why don't you make a
90 minute movie for a thousand dollars
and i wound up getting like 10 i think 10 or 12 to
do it but we did it and it was fun and um you know
you grow i mean you make your projects to grow
but sometimes the right thing comes along and
when you get to the point you are in my life where
where i'm at it's you're there you're gonna make
money doing this or you're not are you doing it
for the money don't do them if you're doing them
because you want to stay relevant you're doing
it because you want to keep the muscles tone
because you believe in something or someone
or you just want to like right now we've been
indoors for five and a half months i i'll go
pay to work right now i mean i just want to
get out of the house and yell action and cut
and argue with an actor and yell at a dp about
something or a pa for wearing a red shirt i
don't care you know for me it's just i mean
i've literally been sitting on my ass for five
and a half months now we've been very productive
but i still have been sitting on my ass for
five and a half months so do i want to sit
at home and not make money or do i want to go
out and have some fun with people i care about
and create and have something to show for the
year so there's there's no limits on budget or
any of that for me it's just go how much you got
what do you want to make let's do it that's how i
work what are some of the things that independent
filmmakers skip over thinking oh i don't need to
spend a lot of money on that but actually that's
dangerous for them to do that you know i always
say there's five things that really make a film
look low or no budget and it's it's cinematography
it's the sound it's the actors you choose it's
the editing and it's the locations and if you
can step up in those five arenas and get the best
that you can and then really try to get better
you're gonna you're gonna have a project that
is just a step above you know i spent a lot of
years judging different film festivals um
obviously the workshops and things that i
do with different schools so i i see it all and
when you start a film and it's shot just so bad
and there's no thought to framing or composition
or anything it's it's just you're done
and the sound it's bad sound is is so easy
to get and it's one of those things that
i i watch more people chance on and getting
a good sound uh sound recording uh on the set
everybody likes user friends and lovers and their
movies chances are your friends and lovers are not
good actors there are so many film schools there
are so many acting classes that you can call
and say i'm doing a student project i'm doing a
spec film i want actors that are good and know
their craft and you know what they will sign up
to do it because they need tape you you ask your
girlfriend or your friends either because you're
afraid to ask real talent and they may not like
your work or want to do it and that's where
you're wrong or b because you're afraid your
girlfriend will leave you if you don't put her
in your movie and that's you know i read about
that in the book um it's kiss to death i mean
if your girlfriend's a good actor give her a
roll but i would be very careful in in casting
and editorial is important um you know editing
is everything i i spent many years in the edit
bay before i considered myself a filmmaker and i
i learned what not to do in the edit bay and it
really it makes me sad when people i think about
his writing or their their cinematography
real or you know the end result without
thinking about the most important result in the
filmmaking process which is really the editorial
and also the cinematography i think they work
very much hand in hand locations are key because
anybody can shoot in their house anybody can shoot
in their kitchen anybody can shoot in their car
our job as storytellers to take people places
where they can't go where they wish to go or
where they're afraid to go and if you give them
locations that are just you know interesting and
break break the monotony of every other low-budget
film i think you'd be surprised how much more
success you can have with your film you know i
i had a wonderful drama teacher and i i always
quote him mr kilpatrick from high school and his
favorite saying was come up with three ways to
do something and go with the fourth and i wish i
remember that more often i'd probably have better
movies that were more successful if i did but
especially young filmmakers you know hey i could
shoot this at my house okay scrap that there's
one idea you're not doing it i can shoot it in
my garage okay that's even worse it's still at
the house but no you're not gonna do it shoot it
in the car why you know does i'm all for keeping
dialogue scenes moving so putting them in a car is
a good way to do that but where can you do this
that's different that's just going to make the
viewer feel like they're watching something fresh
and i think locations are key the most important
thing is um you know where people put money where
they shouldn't is it seems to be the wrap parties
i i'm a i'm a big anti-wrap party guy um it's
just money that's never going on the screen
it's money that you're more interested
in the social media aspect of people
cooing over your your you know your wrap party
and i think it's important to have a gathering
of the people that have worked hard for the
film but do it smart it's like when we do a
film we try to schedule our biggest cast days
on the last day and something centrally located
so people who aren't involved in the last day
can come visit the last day and we'll spend a
little extra money on the catering we may go
and buy 10 bottles of champagne for the day
not expensive ones but and put a simple
day for the last day so we can end early
no stress and then party right there we don't need
to go rent out bowling alleys we need to go rent
out you know all these places it's just money
that doesn't go on the screen and when you're
making especially independent films every dime
counts why are you gonna blow it in one night
that's never gonna go on the screen think about it
i know people that have spent 25 grand on a film
and they'll spend five grand on a wrap party and
i'll watch the film and say why didn't you get a
real editor we couldn't afford one really you know
you could have gotten so and so for three grand
to do that look at so-and-so's resume oh they've
cut 15 studio films that went number one they've
cut 18 sitcoms that are like tier sitcoms that on
their off time will happily moonlight and gladly
get involved and get their hands
dirty for fun for a little money
and that's always the excuse well we couldn't
afford it but it's always something else that
they can afford that just doesn't matter
and i think they just have to re-prioritize
sadly i think social media has become the
driving force but behind what people do
i look i know when i'm shooting a movie 18 months
later when the movie comes out nobody's going to
care about our set pitch look people want to post
on instagram and facebook hey we're on set look
at us great it's not going to sell one ticket
it's not going to sell one dvd it's not going
to get one download it's about how you build up
to the end and its release and there's something
you don't want to give us you know you don't
want to give people overexposure you don't want
to make people punch drunk on your pictures
of the same same same with no results or no
output you know so we try to be very careful when
we promote our films and not do it for years of
social media hype and likes it doesn't
sell any movies it's not going to work
i want to go back to something that you said that
was really interesting you said you wrote about
it in your book and that is using a girlfriend
you could also fill in boyfriend family member
co-worker cousin right whoever um how do you have
that conversation with that person because you
know you want to keep the relationship
with the person or maybe you don't but
let's suppose you do want to keep the relationship
how do you say listen do you audition them the way
everyone else does i think it's a lose-lose i say
if you're a young filmmaker don't date an actor
i'm married to an actor um and we have a great
relationship she did four years on general
hospital she's been in a lot of fun movies and
there's never a person like for me i always try
to put my wife in and and just have her there to
be a ball but she produces with me she's involved
in the post-war we work on a film together for
eight to twelve months having her be a part of it
on camera is something i like to let her flex that
muscle and have fun and she's good she knows her
crap she's good at what she does but she doesn't
have expectations for me either she understands
it's a business i don't like having her in front
of the camera as a director i just i i i am not as
gracious with her as i probably could be i could
be better as a husband to a wife who's acting
um and that's just probably my fault it's just
you know i i just it's not a dynamic that i love
but we found a way to make it work and she's
been in every film i've done over the last
15 20 years and it's worked but um to get back to
your question i think you have to decide are you
in this to showcase a whole bunch of friends
or are you here to make a career and if you're
going to become a doctor you're going to become
an architect if you're going to become a lawyer
are you going to spend all those years in college
and bring your friends along with you while you're
studying taking your tests and learning the craft
of medicine i don't think so so i think filmmaking
communities are important and yes relationships
build you're going to meet women in film school
or actors on the set that you're going to fall
in love with but i think you really have to think
above the shoulders and think what is what is
the purpose of this project and what do i hope
to gain out of it and selfishly you have to build
what's best for the project there's nothing harder
than when you've got somebody you love who's in
front of the camera that is just atrocious and
they just sink the ship what i always try to do
coming up is i would i would find ways to utilize
people's gifts in ways that wouldn't sink the ship
you know i always say to somebody well you want to
work in the industry anyway if you weren't
going to act what else would you want to do
well you know why don't you produce this with me
i need somebody to handle sag paperwork i need
somebody to handle our locations and then you
know what throw them in under five throw them
something expendable or if god forbid it's
awful get rid of it and i'm sorry to talk so
so straight the only way to get rid of a problem
is to not have a problem or to be able to get
yourself out of a problem and if you know you're
starring your girlfriend who can't remember a
line or hit a mark or understand the the craft
of the the respect the craft of acting enough
to know it why are you wasting your time it
just doesn't make sense i i don't have much much
grace or uh i'm not very soft harder when it comes
to that i say just don't even don't even go there
yeah i think it's not just girlfriends
though i think if there's friendships
that are built around you know people
whatever it is being in films together
that's great and i think it could just be a
really difficult thing for people to handle
yeah i mean ed burns was very lucky with brothers
mcmullen i mean he had some very talented friends
but i mean you know that happens once in a while
shane black you know he grew up at that you know
coming off overland in west la and he kind of
lived in that famous house with writers and
actors and storytellers and these guys all kind of
helped each other out and built the machine it's
very rare uh you know the the wilson brothers
owen and um and the other one got him blinking
luke yeah i mean talented and they ran you know
did bottle rockets and all their friends and
there's ways to do it napoleon dynamite did it too
but by and large you think about how many young
filmmakers are out there and we always go for
hey mom do you want to play the mom in my short
you know when you were steven
spielberg and seven that worked
but when you're in film school you're
trying to make a career for yourself
you know again call the acting schools you know
there are a lot of acting schools that have some
decent talented people that would sure love
to be a part of your film and they will take
it seriously and they will learn to learn the role
and the craft is there and the talent is there and
you know uncle vinnie playing dad is
not always the best idea you know just
you know i mean now look i'll often
use an owner of a location if i know
they're a sag actor and they're good like i
have i have friends that own locations that
are actually working good actors i'll say
hey i'll trade you off i want your location
but i'll give you i'll give you a few
lines in this movie like oh yeah sign me up
but they're working actors also you know so i
think you always have to try to put the right
people in when you can with the exception of
with locals in certain films especially if it's
like a certain region of the us or or other
part of the world there's just people that
you just can't you can't get that from central
casting it's too good you know and and you can
you can definitely tell but it works in the
film you know so we're talking about getting
some uh some people that you just you just
find just the gems oh it's you know casting
is it's interesting i say as filmmakers you want
to make friends with a lot of different agencies
uh to this day i will i will reach out to friends
that own boutique agencies you've never heard of
and say i'm doing a film i need a cashier at a
country store i need a hipster who can play guitar
at a campfire i need somebody who can you know be
a drug dealer on the corner or i'll call a drug
dealer in a corner and say hey you want to play
yourself in a movie i'll give you 50 bucks you
know i mean sometimes you got to do that um i find
the people that are the best together the people
that do what it is you want them to do if you're
not hiring an actor again it to me it's always
about getting the best person you can in front
of and behind the camera so if you need something
and you're not getting it with what you're
auditioning go find somebody who does it and tell
them i just need you to be yourself i want you
to be a part of this i'm not going to embarrass
you i just i need and you'd be amazed i mean i
learned that from my dad you know we worked with
probated youth for a lot of years and we had a lot
of of kids in our life that we knew that had done
a lot of crooked stuff and i remember one time we
got a pilot um for uh i think it was time warner
television or warner cable court tv something like
that and they wanted a bunch of reenactments of
burglaries and assaults and all that at the
end of the day we ended up i think hiring
eight or nine of the kids that we worked
with that had done time in real prison
to play parts and they did better than anybody
they knocked it out of the park because it's
who they were and look at homeboys industry inc is
that father boyle yeah i mean you got father boyle
at homeboy industries i mean we i first learned
about that when we were shooting great iron
gang half the extras you walk around you go you
just know when you've worked around real inmates
most your life like i have the swagger the way
they walk the way they talk the way they move
and i remember saying at one point i said where'd
we get all these guys because i know they've done
time and said oh this great thing going on
called homeboy industries inc you've got to
check it out all these kids have done time and i
was like that that makes sense that's so cool and
so i'm a big fan of that yeah sure yeah there's
nothing worse when someone is supposed to play
someone in the underworld let's say and
they're so squeaky clean and it just takes you
out and and there are there's there's mannerisms
there's just different signs and yeah watch a lot
of music videos from the 80s because they would
put a lot of the rock stars girlfriends in when
they were supposed to be down without homeless
girls and you'd see these like not tiny contain
on the jaguar hood but you know you would see
supermodels literally with like shoe polish
on their face digging through a you know a bin
looking for food and you're like oh come on yeah
yeah when you work with dwayne johnson and was it
2006 on the gridiron gang did you have any idea
he would be the star that he is today well i'm not
surprised that he became the star that he is today
um the guy is he he goes in 150 on
everything he does he doesn't do anything
half cocked um his commitment to excellence i
think it comes from his upbringing uh and also his
you know he was an accomplished football player
in college played with the national champion
team with the miami hurricanes and then obviously
what he accomplished as a wrestler and his humble
beginnings and if you know anything about him you
know huge disappointments going through football
the nfl and the cfl and then having to start and
beg vince mcmahon for a job at you know these 150
a night barnyard wrestling tours that they were
doing and you look at where he truly came from and
and just his passion his devotion and his his
commitment to learning the craft and making it as
good as i think i think there are those few people
that you say he can accomplish anything he wants
i i think that's somebody i'd put on top of the
list absolutely do you remember anything notable
from being on set with dwayne johnson yeah i
mean sure i mean you know it was a memorable time
and fortunately i you know proud to say that we
remained good friends um you know here we are 14
years later um still can call him a friend still
in touch he's you know as i said he his commitment
to excellence is second to none he takes so
much pride and you ever talk about somebody who
when they talk to anybody it didn't matter if it
was the guy who was cleaning the toilets it didn't
matter if it was an extra it didn't matter if it
was the director or me producer or anybody when
when he talked to you he was there 100 percent
it was all about this moment with that whoever he
talked to and i think the most memorable time for
me when we were making the film was we were about
two or three weeks in we were shooting uh
during the summer it was probably may or june
and we were shooting up at the prison in malibu
where we actually my father and i shot the
documentary we went back and shot the scripted
piece with dwayne there and he got really sick
he got a flu something when it was food poisoning
or what it's something something happened and
you know it's one of those things you know
the medics were called you know just it wasn't
he was it was just you know you're star sick
you get the medic there you have a medic on set
and they were checking his his blood and it's this
and that and and it was like first thing he was
gonna say is look you know we're here for three
months dude you want to call he said no no no no
i got this he goes i just need i need 10 minutes
let me just give me 10 minutes let me hydrate let
me let some of the aspirin kick in let me we'll
do this and what was interesting it was his first
real deep scene with one of the kids where he was
interacting with one of the kids from the program
and i don't know if anybody remembers
the film it's a scene where he's
encounters the the samoan running back junior in
the middle of the yard at night the kid had a call
because it was his daughter's birthday and he was
pissed that he was missing his birthday and dwayne
wouldn't let him be part of the football program
because he had a hair trigger all he did was fight
and spend all his time in solitary so dwayne
sit down you're not going to be any part of the
team so what this scene was was the two of them
coming together and this kid convincing dwayne
that he can be a part of the program and be a
productive part of it and i knew at that moment
you know we've all seen people tough it out but
you want to talk about being able to completely
block out what he was dealing with and rise to
the occasion or accept the challenge which was
the saying on gridiron gang he did it and
i knew at that moment i said god this guy
you know he he wasn't created we'll
just say that you know there's enough
created fabricated tough guys in hollywood
or greats in hollywood and and i knew at that
moment this guy was genuine he was sincere
he was passionate and you know went all in
take us back to the documentary that you
did how did that come about funny story
um we my father my stepmother and i had done a
host of reality shows before the term was a term
there were documentaries uh on probated youth
it started with desperate passage back in 1986
then became made in voyage desperate passage
was with michael landon made in voyage with
sharon glass then it was a step apart with marlo
thomas and then you know eddie james almost had
done a few of them and they were just they had got
you know these wonderful great actors to host or
narrate these documentaries about probated youth
that we did and it was basically they were done to
show america the hearts cry of
troubled youth that they are still kids
that they weren't raised they were basically
put out and often were raised by street gangs or
you know by pimps and drug dealers and that these
these were still children they were still human
beings that deserved a chance and um like you
know we learned over the years that a kid didn't
care what you thought unless you unless you
knew you cared and then once we broke through
that some remarkable things happened and we
ended up doing things about eight or nine
so we had done a slew of these and had a lot of
success and a couple of studios that optioned
a few of them to be turned into scripted
films and my stepmom linda who i call mom but
my mom was reading the la times and there was a
story in the metro section about one of the jails
that we had done a lot of filming at was starting
a football team within the confines of the jail
and the hope was that these kids would be allowed
to go out and play against the straight schools
and they started with an eight-man football
team or seven-man team the first year and then
the second year when we heard about it and it
finally made press was they were they were gonna
fill a full team so mom came into the office and
was all excited threw the thing down on my dad's
desk and said oh my god this is this is a movie
my dad was like yeah yeah we we've done these and
linda god bless her mom she was like no no no no
no this is the one this is the one so she pushed
him pretty hard so after a few days he called
probation and said hey it's lee how you doing
we want to come up we'd love to do a documentary
we saw the article in the la times and we've been
doing this with probation at this point for seven
years we've had all the success and done well
and they kind of laughed us off and said yeah
get in line like what are you talking about well
ever since that article came out every studio in
hollywood wants to do it we're engaging you name
the actor you name the producer they're trying
to negotiate the rights this is this is out of
your wheelhouse guys you know so we kind of we're
like well that's too bad that we we got excited
about it assuming it was going to be ours and we
lost it so about three weeks went by and the head
of probation called my father and said are you
still interested in doing the uh the the story
on the prison football team and my father said
well why i thought you had hollywood's elite
yeah we we do and we have and we got a quick quick
crash course on how hollywood does things and we
all decided we kind of like the way you guys do
things so if you'd like to do it the rights are
yours we'll see here they start practice in
three days and we didn't have any money and
we we ended up just beg borrowing and stealing
some cameras and got the funding after the fact
we'd like raced up to get it because i mean how
do you call somebody say we need funding in three
days we just we kind of knew what we could go to
some of our trusted investors from the past shows
but we just rolled the dice and grabbed
a couple cameras and sound and a small
crew of four of us is what it usually was and
went up and shot and we made the documentary
we got the funding and when i say the funding
i think it was probably 200 000 dollars to
to make this documentary and what was
really funny is in making it um you know
we covered the first game and what you saw in
the the film with the rock was a direct lift i
mean basically jeff mcguire our writer watched
the documentary and just wrote what was there
it's all there and it was interesting because the
kids had lost their first game cried like babies
we all went our separate ways that was a movie
it was over as far as we were concerned it was
over and my father was speaking uh for janet
reno who was the attorney general at the time
in atlanta for a big fbi conference they wanted my
dad there because he understood so much about the
youth of today and incarcerated youth and they
just kind of wanted to understand from somebody
who'd worked 20 years with these kids kind of to
hear his take on it not being a clinical psych or
a cop you know let's let's hear somebody who's
worked with these kids different point of view
so my dad goes to atlanta with my mom and they're
gone and it was like they've made a week out of it
because my uncle lived in florida and they were
going to spend time with them i get this phone
call from my father he said hey uh what are you
doing this weekend and i was like i'm just hanging
out what's up he said you know the documentary
we did on the film with the football team i said
of course he said well those little brats are
playing for the state championship i need you to
get a couple cameras i need you to go handle it
and then there's an awards banquet after that i
need you to go deal with it i'm stuck in atlanta
so i had to scramble and get a couple of great
cameramen i think it was phillip hearn and steve
elkins and chip brooks did sound and me directing
and we went out and shot their championship game
against montclair prep where they lost 13 to 7
and and then the awards banquet at the
old sportsman's lodge right after that
and then that was it and that's how it came
about and nobody wanted it it was interesting
with all the success we had nobody wanted it it
sat um was steve bell who had basically given
us anything we wanted at ktla and tribune
to launch our shows was no longer there he
had gone to start i think stars or encore so
we were dealing with a new regime at ktla and
tribune and they didn't really capture the vision
and our agents at caa at the time watched it and
said that's a that's a cute little documentary and
you know my dad went back to get the vhs from the
projectionist at caa and he was wiping his eyes he
said i heard what he said don't listen to a word
this is one of the most powerful things i've
ever seen you're going to do great with this
and we finally got it on tv it won an emmy for
uh i don't know what the heck it won for but
it was it was a big national emmy it won my dad
and uh the day after it aired on tv every studio
but paramount called to make a bid every a-list
actor you can imagine was calling i mean we went
into the office the next day there was you know
the thing ran out of tape and the next week the
phone just rang off the hook you know it was
everybody trying to get the rights so it was
an incredible experience it was a whirlwind and
then it took another 14 years to get made so can
we can we have a condensed version of those 14
years and why do you think that's really nothing
okay why do you think that is well it was easy
i mean you know mark canton ran the studio uh if
they had to have it because everybody else wanted
it they paid the most and gave us the prettiest
pitch so jeff mcguire had just written the uh in
the line of fire with clint eastwood and wolfgang
pedersen and got the academy award nomination
so he was our writer so the film acquired two
million and a half i think two and a half million
dollars of studio costs against it and then canton
was out he was fired and the new regime came in
and usually what happens is all those films that
have been sitting around going to turn around
so they put gridiron in a turnaround they were
like yeah you know whatever this is the old so
after uh 18 months of development another reason
i don't like it the film sat with a two and a
half million dollar lien against it and i don't
think a month went by in 12 years where somebody
didn't call and say what's going on with gridiron
we'd love to make it and we said hey there's a
two and a half million dollar fee against it if
you want to pay off sony we can start from
scratch and make the movie and most people
would hang up before we were done with the
sentence it was like yeah not gonna happen
and uh um yeah so 14 years went by it was from
1993 till 2005. so what is that 12 years went by
and then neil moritz who we had known years ago
when he first started his career with juice and
stoned age we always had a respect for each other
and neil had become obviously quite the producer
with things like fast and furious and a whole
list of other films and just called it neil one
day when i heard friday night lights was getting
done and they were gonna make invincible they were
gonna make we are marshall they were making facing
the giants we talked earlier about how hollywood
likes to keep doing the same thing called neil and
said do you want to make red iron gang he said yes
let's do it and we had a meeting my father and
i went and saw neil and he said do me a favor
before you come to my office shane give me a
list of cast he said this thing has fallen on
its face time and time again it's about the
cast we got to make this thing cast right so
i spent the night putting together a cast that i
thought was going to change the world and put the
world on its ear and while doing that my wife
girlfriend at the time val said come in here
i want you to see what i'm watching on tv and i
ignored her i said i'm busy i'm playing hollywood
producer she came into my office and she had tears
pouring down her face and said you need to you
need to come in here she said i got your guy and i
said come on man really she said come in well she
was watching the a e biography on the rock and you
know he had been arrested i think a dozen times
before his 18th birthday football saved him and
how he thought he was going to be an nfl player
coming off a championship college team and ended
up breaking his neck or rupturing all his discs
started over from nothing and i watched and
was just fascinated and i literally hit the
delete button on the document on my on my
computer went in to see neil the next day
we caught up hadn't seen each other in person in
a while congratulated him on all of his success
and he said great all right where's your
list and i said i didn't make a list and
you can see he deflated and i said i got the i
got the guy he said kind of needed a list what
do you got and i said the rock and he thought
for a minute and he yelled to his assistant
and said when's my meeting with the rock and
she said you're having dinner with him tomorrow
he looked at me and he said i'm having dinner with
him tomorrow we're trying to figure out something
to do this could be the one he said get me a
copy of the the documentary you guys did on dvd
and let's find that original script that mcguire
wrote 15 years ago he was probably going to need
to be dusted off and modernized but i want to
go with that script just give me the dvd and
have it back here by tomorrow i'm having dinner
with them tomorrow night so i didn't have a dvd
of gridiron gang it was on vhs so i found a place
that converted it for me in literally a half a day
sunset video ran it down to neal's office just
in time and two days later neil called and said
duane wants to meet you guys and we hung out
at the jail and it was a great experience and
he he encountered the kids and saw what we were
doing and said i commit let's make the movie and
14 years later we were
rolling camera and that was it
so that that meeting took place and then
he committed to it so take me on why people
were passing on it i'm confused sorry
why were people passing on it within that
time when he hadn't reached the level that he
is now at i'm confused nobody passed on it once
once he signed on and went right to sony we had a
green light picture he was very much in demand it
was the documentary that we struggled to get seen
uh i see like doing the documentary and having
tremendous success i mean we had already won 12
emmys and had 32 nominations and nobody wanted to
watch this one which was kind of part of the same
genre sure as yeah and then finally we kind of
bartered a deal at ktla to get them to put it on
and once it got on every studio wanted it so
we spent eight months getting quartered by
everybody from disney to sony to warner to
universal and then went with sony and then
canton developed it and then he got fired so then
everything just wanted to turn around so it's that
we just we couldn't do anything with it because
there was a 2 million lien against it from sony
and what was really cool maybe this will
help clarify neil because of his reputation
and his deals that he had at sony he was like
look the two and a half million dollars they're
claiming needs to be paid back he goes that was
14 years ago that money's been written off it's
done it's gone it's a new regime i will deal with
that and neil went in and talked to amy pascal who
who captured the vision of the project he
was very excited about it and said all right
let's wave the two and a half let's let's put
a new let's put this back on a fast track and
you know get a start we want we're excited about
let's do it fortunately they were excited about
dwayne and we were rolling he had to go shoot
a film i think it was doom or the game plan and
then i think it was doom and then as soon
as he got back we started ours immediately
and then off we went and then what was the
reception once the the narrative version
was finished once the film came out it did very
well it was frustrating because we finished it
in uh i think it was oh i want to say oh five or
six and in september we were supposed to come out
during the super bowl like build up to the super
bowl we wanted to give him that football movie
and at the last minute sony decided yeah we're
going to push it another nine months we'll come
out in september so it's like oh it's only
been 13 years what's another nine months
film came out it went number one did very
well it was number one for two weeks um
it did well i think the fact that there
were three other football movies out like
invincible and we are marshall and facing the
giants didn't help us but it's still i think it
did 30 or 38 million domestic in the box office
one thing that you don't hear about was we were
very fortunate with home video sony created
blu-ray as we all know and there was a race
between two mediums it was blu-ray and another
home high-def system i don't remember what it was
and sony decided when they launched blu-ray
they were going to do it on two films they
did spider-man 2 and they did gridiron so
what happened is this gridiron came back and
dwayne had become such a big star during that
time the dvd and what little vhs sales were
were very very strong and then when they recycled
it for blu-ray why it was still relevant it more
than doubled again so it had this extra boost
that nobody expected which was really special
so yeah that was that was gridiron it did well
it was fun and you know it's nice to to have that
that in my resume and i don't mean that it's it's
you know a career that's now 48 years going it's
nice to have had the number one blockbuster
and it gives me we talked about chasing
that success i had as a 16 year old it
gave me that validation it hit 30 37 36
and it it it really reminds me everything's okay
you know maybe every 10 15 years i'll have one
but maybe i won't again but it's okay i
i slayed the dragon and i can just move
forward and be comfortable with what i do
and you had some people give you advice as
well that had also had success early in life
who who kind of like put things in perspective
i know i was very very fortunate you
know with some of the the people that i
run with or worked with or befriended over the
years you know people that come to mind or people
like charlie sheen or brett michaels uh you know
there's the singer from poison obviously rock of
love celebrity apprentice everybody knows brat
now uh from all different different places and
brett and i have been best friends since probably
93 or 94. and here's a guy who had tremendous
success came from very humble beginnings you know
him and other guys from poison jumped in evandro
from harrisburg pennsylvania to l.a lived in an
abandoned warehouse or an abandoned laundromat
for three years trying to make it and they had in
the 80s and 90s had so much success and then the
music styles changed and talk about a guy who
was able to reinvent himself you know brett's
had to reinvent himself three times and he's done
well every time and the one thing he taught me was
the cool thing is you know when he had every
rose has its thorn was his number one hit
so we we kind of joked about i had my gridiron he
had his every rose it was kind of funny when that
finally happened and he said here's the cool thing
about that nobody can ever take it away from you
he goes there will be another 52 movies this year
that'll go number one he goes that's fine but you
still went number one and i never forgot that i
never wore that conceitedly or with arrogance but
it was it gave me the affirmation that i think
so many artists you know you want that and that
that helped um but he always gave me
the greatest advice he always said
no one to get off the merry-go-round you know
we talked about that you know getting off the
merry-go-round at the right time there's people
that jump off it too soon and it's still moving
too fast and that's not good you know you
think about getting off a merry-go-round too
fast it'll kill you and then there's the people
that hang on it too long and it comes to a stop
and people are waiting for you to get off
he said what you have to do is figure out
how to ride certain moments of your career
and know when to step away and it's never easy
you know when i say that i talk about a
film that you have a film that does well
you can you can i'll use a very generic term
you can milk that as long as you think you can
but you try not to over milk it you try not to
hinge your your future on it you realize hey we
were fortunate we were blessed we had a moment in
time that nobody can take from us and there are
going to be 51 other number one movies this year
so we need to get moving and let the next people
come in and do what they need to do and enjoy
the moment and let's go on and go back to work
so i've had some good advice with some people in
my life that have kind of been that done there
i think that you know been very helpful to
me why not give up on the project earlier
10 years in you're talking about
giving it up why it was sitting at sony
well we did because it was in turn around and i
didn't have two and a half million dollars laying
around with accruing interest to pay them off to
get it back the one thing that always gave us hope
was as i said i don't think a month went by
in 12 years where somebody called and said hey
what's going on there was actually a time where
peter gruber called and said um i know you've got
your your deal with sony that's got to be paid
off i used to be head of sony i may be able to
make that work i really would like to try to make
this into something so we we did a deal with with
mandalay peter guber before we ended up making
it with neil um there were a few people that that
would try to do some creative so when you have
a project and it's it's generating that interest
for so long with people with that kind of juice
you never want to throw that away you know we
talked earlier about what's a good script what's
a good story what can you use to get a foothold
in this industry well when you have a product and
you've got the peter goobers or the neil moritzes
or the joe roths or the bobby neumeyers calling
you on a regular basis saying what's going on man
let's you know well okay there's something there
you don't just bury it you can't you can't so i
think there was always the hope that it would get
done one day i think my dad and i had always kind
of said you know one day maybe something will
come along maybe we'll have success somewhere
else enough where we can buy out that two million
and get it done you know um but it all worked out
and so when you filmed at the sportsman's lodge
both schools were there right for this dinner
no this was all for the kids oh okay it's all
for the mustangs interesting yeah and i don't
think it was a sportsman's lodge it was it was
a shh it was it's where it's where um there's a
sushi spot there right now it's an all you can eat
sushi place off wineca and tampa across from the
ash it used to be called the smorgasbord inn it
was a sports banquet lodge similar to sportsman's
lodge but it wasn't so you have to put that in but
it's so funny i just say sportsman's lodge because
everybody knows it but it was like the swedish
inn or something like that okay yeah it was it
was the parents and the kids and sadly there was
only a few parents you know we had 48 kids on the
team and i think eight parents showed up it was
tragic i'm sad that's just that's the way it is
how much should a filmmaker pay
themselves whatever they can
i mean you know at the end of the day it depends
you know when i say filmmaker i think about me
i'm involved concept to delivery
you know i just got into it with
somebody the other day who worked on
our last film and they worked i think
four to six weeks on breakeven i just
celebrated my 27th month on the film last week
now we lost five months of covid but during the
covet time we had to repurpose our distribution
outlets what we were going to do so i ended up
dealing with a whole new list of deliverables
a whole new group of people with different qc
demands you know for quality control for release
so you know there are people on that film that
worked three or four weeks i got paid a hell of
a lot more than i did and you know here i am i'm
literally like almost two and a half years in and
i wouldn't change a thing about it i don't do it
for the money i do it because i love to do it i i
just i enjoy the process but you know i always say
be fair you're going to have an investor that you
want to be able to have an open books relationship
with if you have an investor that says i'd like to
see the books you don't want to that's not a good
position to be in there are plenty of people you
can google in hollywood who have gone to prison i
always say just when you hand an investor a budget
you live by it and you can put clauses in your
financing agreement that say hey if we come in
under budget i get to keep it or if i come
in under budget let's split what's left or
you know but i i think whatever you can
pay yourself if you're raising the money
you're creating the content you're creating
jobs for you know and break even 125 people
you know get what you can you know because
you're going to give the money back to your
investors i trust so you may never see another
dime you know so i i never try to tell people
what they should or shouldn't pay themselves i
just say if you were the investor of the film and
you your filmmaker was being paid what
you're paying yourself would you feel
comfortable looking would you would you would
you be okay looking at those books and i think
if you can answer yes that's fine i've never had
an investor i've never had an investor ask me in
30 years of raising independent money how much i'm
paying myself i've had their lawyer ask me once
one time i had a lawyer ask me and i've never been
asked since and i was very direct with the lawyer
at the time i belonged to four unions and i said
well i'm a union member for the following guilds
i will be doing all four of these jobs on the
film i am not going to be taking my union rates
i have parked my union membership so i could do
this project this is what i normally get paid
here's what i'm doing it for and he was like
wow okay i just he was like i just didn't know
i thought he was questioning my value he just was
curious but um i i say you know you're gonna be
you know every film is a love affair you're gonna
walk away from it scarred heartbroken chipped
teeth black guys gray bald fat thin it's it's
gonna it's gonna do this to you you know you're
gonna lose 20 pounds in pre-production you're
going to put on a few pounds during production
and you're going to put on 25 pounds of post you
know so i i just say you know be fair to yourself
um realize that this is going to be probably a
year to an 18-month process and what is your time
worth and uh don't bankrupt the project because
you have to be greedy or get paid you don't budget
yourself accordingly you're a line item you know
every job you do is a line item if you if you're
writing a script you're you should be paid as a
writer if you're producing you should be paid as
a producer if you're directing it the same and
editing it the same if you're supervising music
and doing post-production and deliverables that
cost somebody's gotta get paid to do it right
so which production taught you the most you
don't have to name names or the name of the
movie or who you work with but it just taught you
the most whether it was something about yourself
whether it was something about
how you were working with people
something where it changed you in a lot of ways
could be for better or worse i you know i grew
up as you know doing independent shoestring
thread budgets with my dad i mean we were doing we
were doing films that had million dollar budgets
for 20 grand back in the day when we were shooting
in film and i learned so you have to learn so much
if you're gonna make it work i mean we literally
did these films on crews of three to five
so you could be shooting a camera and you
could be also holding a boom pole and mixing an
fp32 mixer on your hip as you're trying to pull
focus and shoot and you kind of become those you
know those musicians that were the the symbols on
your knees and the bass drum and the tambourine
on their head and you kind of do a lot of that i
think i got shape doing those the first major film
i produced was a 12 million film for miramax back
in the day and it was frustrating because i knew
how to do so much and wasn't allowed but what
was really cool when we got there i still got
to do so much i had co-written the script and i'd
produced the film one of the producers of the film
and before we were done i ended up doubling for
one of the big stars i ended up cutting the film
and ended up being you know working with the
post supervisors and the music supervisors and
i got to do a lot of things again and that
was really fun and i it reminded me that
you know when you work in big budgetville
it's funny there's people to do everything
you know it's spread out so much but i come from
a a place where everybody did it so much and i i
like when everybody does so much and what's funny
is after living in covid going back to work where
the demands or the crews are smaller the people
who know how to do much are the ones who are going
to be called because i know when we're crewing
up for this new film that we're gearing up to do
everybody's got to be able to do a lot
of things i mean even my camera operators
they got to be able to do a lot of things you know
my my it's no longer hair makeup and wardrobe and
props it's one person who's going to handle all
four of those it's the only way it's gonna work
you know and uh so i learned from everything every
production i've ever done karen i learned from
and i i appreciate each experience i
learned something new on every show
what's the worst piece of advice you've
received and it actually turned out to be true
but at the time when you heard it you
thought i'm not listening to this person
worst piece of advice i ever
got that turned out to be true
i think the worst advice i ever got that
turned out to be true was um was something
that my photo teacher taught me in my
senior year in high school mr ken neely
he uh he called me in after class one day and
he said i'm worried about your future he said
you're a jack of all trade master of none and i
said what do you mean he said well you're here in
photo class you're doing okay you take a decent
picture because you race dirt bikes you play
drums in a band and you've won an emmy already you
know what's your plan dude like you gotta like and
i got really concerned about that and i gave
up a lot of things in my life because of that
and what's weird is i don't know if
that was bad advice but it was true
and i didn't listen to the advice and i just
became this guy that did a lot of things
that i i do well enough to to work and
to stay relevant am i a great storyteller
no am i a great director that's
putting the world on their on their ear
no not reinventing the wheel am i a great editor
that's gonna you know come up with a way to cut a
film differently than anybody else has no so i'm
not able to put all of my energy into one thing
i am really glad now that i'm almost 50 i've been
able to stay working for as long as i have because
i did become a jack of all trade i don't
think if i if if i had listened to his advice
and not pumped the brakes after a year and a half
of getting rid of everything in my life that was
important to me i would have truly learned the
craft of everything i could so i know that's not
the answer to the question you asked but that
is the one thing that has constantly haunted
me over the years was the advice did i do it
right what did i give up and then how did i
reboot myself and then i looked later and i go
well i i've actually been i'm okay so you know
did you tell other people about that conversation
and did they steer you away from doing too much
it's funny every time i start a film everybody
tells me you do too much we're going to be here
to support you you do too much we're going to take
a lot of it off you and i don't know if it's me
not truly embracing and trusting
the people i work with enough to
to trust that that's gonna happen or it's
going to be okay um i'm not a control freak
i'm very hands-on but i've also been around too
many productions when people assume somebody's
going to take care of something and it's just it's
unacceptable when they fall through the cracks and
i'm just somebody that knows if i handle it it
won't doesn't mean i'm perfect it doesn't mean
i'm great it just means that i know if it's on
my list to do's it's i i know if it's on my list
of to do's it's going to get done and i'm very
hard to trust people with doing those things so
um again i don't know if i'm answering
your question properly but you know i
i have spent my entire career being told by people
well we just want you to direct and we just want
you to deal with this and i haven't been able to
do that because you know i haven't felt that i
haven't had the peace in my heart to do that and
i wish i had and it's nothing anybody has done
it's it's my own problem it's not somebody has
dropped the ball or let me down it's that fear
it's waking up at two in the morning as i talk
about in the book in a sweat scared to death the
wrong actor is going to show up tomorrow scared
to death we didn't get a permit scared to death
that we didn't order the drone or whatever and
i know if i'm handling it it's not going to fall
through the cracks it sounds like too you love
to be busy i do ambidextrous you're always doing
things adhd but same difference right or gemini
yeah so so you just certain people just love to be
they they just have certain ways about
them they love to be busy i love to be
busy i'd love not to be as busy as i am but i
always find that i'm never not i'm never still
i'm never still and i always say i'm going to stop
taking things on and then three days go by and i'm
sitting here looking at four other projects
that i just committed to get involved with
what was i thinking but somehow some way they
get done yeah you know yeah i mean i think
just certain people are hardwired differently i am
definitely hardwired differently but no i mean not
in a bad way but yeah but just wanting to to say
or they they like they have a tv show on they're
cleaning something over here they're looking
at twitter there's just yeah just some people
i don't vacation well i don't i don't take days
off i don't vacation luckily my wife is kind of
we love our little world and what we do and
there's not we're not people that take two weeks
every year to go do anything you know we take day
trips once every week or every other week go do
fun things we we're always together i mean we both
work from home so we're together all the time so
we have our time together but i never oh my god
i gotta get away and go to hawaii or i need to
jump on a plane and go somewhere you know i it's
never been in my dna no cruises no god no what are
the top five reasons an investor will invest
in your project top five reasons an investor
will invest in somebody or their
project i think number one is because
they want to help you i think anytime you go
to an investor it's somebody who's probably in
better circumstance than you are or at least
has the ability to help get you to the next
level make your dreams come true i have had
investors that get behind me simply because
there's a trust level there's a feeling of wanting
to help me get to another level of my career
sometimes it's because they feel the project's
important often it's because they want
to get a tax write-off i mean there's the
business side of the business too you know i i
believe that you know astute investors are
taught by business managers to avoid three
or four different investments one one is
nightclubs and restaurants one is recording
studios and the other is movies i mean that's
just like those are the three you don't do
so getting private equity together for making
motion pictures is is difficult we have kind
of a stigma going in there's already a couple
of strikes against us so what's important is
that we're able to appeal to an independent and
i'm sorry what's important is that we're able to
appeal to individual financiers or investors with
what it is that we're trying to achieve with our
work i think that's really important and i as i
talk about a lot in my book i think it's really
important for for filmmakers to really do their
research on people don't just go meet rich people
meet people who can identify with
what it is you're trying to do
you may have a passion project that you want to
do but you can do your research on a specific
investor and learn that they may have a passion
or an interest think about doing something that
is something that they will be more open or
interested in doing and go down that road
so when you meet with them they're excited and
thrilled about what it is you're trying to pitch
take care of business do that and then they're
going to come usually if it's successful in a good
a good journey and say what is it you want
to do and that's often been the hardest thing
because you know again as filmmakers we're
myopic we think about what we want to do
and often you have to think about what other
people want to do that are in a position of
helping us so i always say go in with an open
heart going with an open mind be willing to
bob and weave a little bit off of your plan at
the end of the day the goal is to work the goal is
to make new relationships i mean i have investors
that we've known for 35 years that have faithfully
gotten involved i have investors that have
invested one time that i've known 25 years and
we're still best of friends and they did it one
time and didn't ruin the friendship it just they
wanted to try and i have i have you know friends
that i've i've known for 25 and 30 years who would
never invest in this business and they are more
than capable it's just to each his own but i think
people will want to i say you know you always
have to remember you're under the watchful eye
if you are going to approach people to invest in
you realize you're going to become an open book
they're going to look at your social media they're
going to look at how you conduct yourself they're
going to invite you to parties where there's
going to be alcohol because they want you to drink
and they want to see how you're going to behave
people don't realize that i mean i know a lot of
real close calls friends of mine have had over the
years we're like god you know i had an investor on
the hook had this party i drank too much passed
out at the guys play well duh you know they're
they're almost saying here let me see how you
do what can i trust you with and just remember
you have to treat their money like it's your money
and i think you know some of the success that
we've had with our investors it's not always about
how much the return on investment was it's about
a trust level it's about the experience let
them feel involved you know i send my investors
emails at the end of every night telling
them good bad or indifferent how the day went
and then once we're in post production i fill them
in once a week and it's that way in pre-production
too i just feel that they they're we're doing
what we do because they trust in us and they
give us the means to do it you have to let
them feel involved and a lot of times these
investors believe it or not are a little bored
doing what they do and they see this as kind
of a neat little fun outlet so involve them you
know let them feel a part of what you're doing
that being said have you ever put money from
a credit card into any of your projects have i
ever put money from a credit card into one of my
projects um oh yeah um there's been times where
i've done uh self-funded projects you know i talk
about the 500 pilot i talk about the 10 000 movie
i mean i had an investor that came to me with 20
dollars and said i wanna make a movie with you and
um didn't account for sag bonds and the fact that
it was kind of a sequel remake to something we did
that was on sag experimental and had to repay all
the actors for the work they did the year before
so that 20 000 turned into 12 000 really quick
and the investor was cool enough to say i'll
throw an additional amount in for the bond but
that's it because he would get his bond back so
we really had about 12 grand to work with and
there was a couple of days that it was kind
of like all right you know let's feed the crew
well tonight and just you know it's part of it
um but i've never had to like max out a
credit card to make a movie or anything i i
haven't had to do that i maxed out credit
cards doing other stupid [ __ ] i know
no swearing i had to throw no more jet skis
though no more jet skis no that's over that's
that's over good question though yeah no i mean
it's about we did dark side i put about 3 500 on
credit cards to feed i just the people weren't
eating well enough and the budget was so cheap
and they were all working for nothing and it
was like goddamn i gotta i gotta feed these guys
so i just i told my wife i'm like i i can't do
the subway and pizza thing for 15 days we're
gonna feed them every three days really well but
we did we did and i think we got i think we got
a good result from that you know and you feed them
well happy crew happy moving right just want to be
fed and respected you know if you invest 250 000
in a movie does that mean it's going to sell for
at least 250 000 oh hell no it's like putting 75
million into a movie and sometimes it makes back
10 million i mean there's no guarantees um
obviously the more money you have to play with
um hopefully the better the cast the more bankable
the cast the more well-known the cast but you
don't always have that i mean we've done a lot of
250 000 movies and i think again it comes down to
telling a good story it comes down to getting
a good cast that's recognizable and marketable
and it's also about those locations you know take
people places they want to go make them never feel
like they're watching a 250 000 movie you know
i take a lot of pride in in my 20 000 movie we
really did for 12 grand a lot of people don't know
the story of that and what it did for my career
i actually got more out of my career because
of that than i did from gridiron gang um and i
did it after gridiron gang what's interesting
is i had done a film i wanted to tell a story
and i um for me it was about showing people what
i could do on a dime that's as you know if you've
read my book it's about making films for a dime
that turn and make a dollar that's what it's about
so for me i went out and we made this let's
just say twelve thousand dollar movie after
i put in a few grand on my credit card to
feed um i had a friend who was very tight
with sumner redstone who at the time who you know
he just passed but sometimes they had a viacom
and friend of mine got it to sumner
and said friend of mine made this
i don't know if you want to watch it or not i want
you to watch it and check it out he's like why
am i watching it well there's pretty girls in it
you'll like it but i want you to watch it for the
production value when you're done watching i want
you to guess what you made it for so sumner sat
through this 90 minute debuckery of mine it wasn't
a great story it just was a pretty movie and he
was pleased and impressed with it and glad he
watched it and he said oh i guess he probably
put a couple million into it and my friend said
well he actually put about 12 grand into it
sumner picked up the phone called brad gray god
rest him he's dead too picked up the phone and
called brad gray and said i just saw a movie
that apparently was made for twelve thousand
five hundred dollars i could have sworn it was
made for a couple million i need to get it to you
film got sent to brad i got a call from brad
gray the next day he said yeah i need you to
start meeting with our people we want to get you
in here i met with les moonves i met with michael
balbre who was running paramount at the time
and it opened up amy powell who was running
in surge which is you know did paranormal
activity and a lot of other great films and
that film opened up a lot of doors for me because
it showed people what i could do for a dime
and it and it allowed my investors to come back
out of the woodwork who i hadn't worked with in
many years because you know you go make a film
with sony you're not hitting people up for a
quarter million dollars to make movies you're
making a you know you're making a studio movie
so it reopened those great opportunities and
kind of just reminded me okay you don't need
big budgets to make something look nice now
we just got to focus on making better movies
and it's been a fun journey but yeah we um
david bulberry was the guy at paramount but um
it it opened those doors for me that
you know having a number one blockbuster
never got me so i really encourage people to
make those low-budget glossy good-looking films
if your story sucks they better look good and i
went in on the merit of guess what i did it for
and people thought you know six hundred
thousand most people who were in the know
figured 600 to a million it was a twenty
thousand fifteen thousand dollar movie
yeah that actually ended up being twelve because
didn't you you lost some of the money what was it
20 credits 20 or 25 000 was the original agreement
but because of our previous jaw with sag and those
actors we had to repay them for their first so we
lost about eight grand of sag so that came down
to about 12 and then you know we ended up you know
probably putting in about 2 800 of my own for food
and stuff so yeah you know about 15 000 wow how
long was the shoot how many times 12 days 12 days
shoot pick did it i did a day of uh i did a day
of second unit with two of the actors because
they were friends of mine they did it off the
grid you know i wanted them in the car driving
you know drive-bys and stuff and then i went out
and just grabbed a camera and just second united
the hell out of it you know got those great magic
hour shots and just filled up the just filled it
up with some pretty you know but it was well shot
it was well acted um you know we had sean young
betsy russell from saw ron masak who's been
in everything courtney gaines from children of
the corn i mean every face in it was recognizable
jason pace ryan um oh i'm blanking on ryan's name
it's my fault there was just some really good
talent in that film and uh i was proud of it
because it looked pretty it was a beautiful movie
it was a horrible movie but it was a beautiful
movie why was it horrible it was just stupid it
was you know i did i i did the first one which
was a pure story about a story i wanted to tell
and that was the pilot that i did for 500 bucks
and somebody saw it and said oh my god you got
to make a sequel to this and that was that was
the mistake story-wise there was no sequel but
somebody was throwing 20 bucks you know 20 grand
down to make a movie i'm not doing anything
this week let's do it you know and so we did it
do you think that if you'd had more time you
guys said it was a 12-day shoot if you'd had
more time would it have been better or no the
story was fundamental it was a horrible script
no it looked good i mean you know again as
a 15 12 to 15 000 movie that some people
thought we spent six hundred thousand to two
million to make so it visually was fine it was
it was just the script was written in like
a week and it was just in no development
notes it was like oh here was the prequel just
just let's just carry on and write and tell a
story and it was it was just you know it's
more of an experiment i see yeah it was fun
what's the shortest amount of time you've written
a script i did a 36 hour fade in to the end
for emmett and furla films um project called bad
news that i wrote for them and i did it and i did
it on a tuesday wednesday thursday without sleep
no drugs without sleep and i crashed thursday at
some point i physically collapsed in my condo
and i woke up at some point friday printed it
out called them and furlough drove it to them at
the warner lot and they optioned it they called me
monday said we love it it's exactly what we need
we want it that was that was three days nonstop
the lack of sleep help you get into a mindset was
it some type of a sci-fi fantasy no no it was an
action film it was i knew the story i wanted to
tell and emmitt and furlough were friends we had
done a film or two with them and they were buying
they were working with people at the time that i
worked with in the past they were working with
avi lerner and cassie elways and mark rifkin and
some of those guys from the late 90s that i had
worked with that were just cranking out these
10 to 20 million dollar action movie so i
knew what they wanted and they were they
were optioning scripts and they were paying to
do it and these guys i pitched george on it over
the phone and he said oh yeah that sounds
cool give me a script and this was like on
tuesday i hung up the phone it was like three
o'clock in the afternoon i just started writing
i started writing and i i collapsed at some
point thursday and realized that i wrote the end
and uh did you wake up and like the room was
spinning or what happened when did someone find
you i was living alone at the time it was after my
first uh my first divorce i was back living alone
uh you know us bachelors when we find
our way back to bachelorhood usually live
it was crazy it was just i remember that time
very vividly and i remember writing it tuesday
afternoon collapsing at some point thursday
and you know every when you wake up friday
everything's still a blur and i just remember
hitting print there was 96 pages and i just
hit print i punched hold them put a brad in them
called their office and make sure dow was there a
guy at the time who was head of of development and
i said dallas shane i'm coming will you give me a
pass he goes yeah yeah we're waiting for you dude
drove onto the warner lot gave it to dow and said
enjoy and george called me i think monday or two
and said yeah dude you got a deal this is great
i i will say george has better taste than
that this was 25 years ago but yeah that was
the fastest script i ever wrote wow yeah a lot of
coffee oh yeah crown and coffee i don't know why
crown oil and coffee oh wow i don't know how an
empty stomach oh wow yeah you gotta stay awake
wow and the little purple bag yeah probably smoked
a lot too so i went through a phase with smoking
a lot i think i probably went through about
19 packs of cigarettes that week good times
they got them vegan now i'm making up you know
trying to take care of myself now that i'm old
that's just quite an image i can i can almost
see it yeah i can tell you another story similar
okay yeah please i'll tell you another funny
story somewhere we did no code of conduct
uh for for dimension which was miramax um it was
a 12 million film we shot we had a green light on
a script charlie sheen starred in it and we had
written it they didn't want to tell that story so
they brought two other writers on couple of great
guys ed masterson and bill gaqwa really cool guys
we ended up becoming very good friends for a long
time actually one of them bought a car from me
and we got to phoenix and the director and charlie
read the script and they go what the what the hell
is this and i said i don't know that's what they
sent you well we start shooting in 48 hours get
your laptop fade in so we rewrote the script in
arizona two days before we shot from page one
and just about page one rewrite that was another
all same time of my life it was within give or
take a few years so i was still able to do that
and how does that work with the original credit
who cares we're just a bunch of dumb people
making movies you know i mean they paid
they paid us we were producing the film they paid
the writers it was like they had to deal with the
writers anyway so those it was like we wrote the
film charlie brett michaels and i wrote the script
and then they agreed to make the movie we went
to phoenix to make the movie and then somebody
got in the mix and said that's not the script we
want to make and hire two writers didn't tell us
anything about it and just sent us a script the
guys never came out to arizona they were just two
guys in la that were told to rewrite a script
that they weren't happy with because it was
originally written for la and then they sent us
to phoenix for a 30 tax credit so we get there and
it's just the domino effect you change the script
like what the hell is this this isn't what we
you know charlie doesn't know why i'm here i
didn't agree to do this and it was our company
charlie brett and i had a company so yeah and they
just said come on dynamo and get some jolt cola or
you know get some coffee and fire it up
let's go and we did it we did a 48 hour
two days before we wrote or rewrote the whole
script and they i don't think they ever knew it
so what was what was our 47 like hour 47 i
remember being in the homestead village they
hadn't set us up in our homes yet they gave
us homes it was a 12 million film in phoenix
in the 90s that's a lot of money they had us
in a homestead village and we each had our own
unit and i remember being in brett's at his
cabinet i probably i probably smoked three
packs of cigarettes a day and just drank coffee
it was nuts and then there was a kenny rogers
roasters that that would deliver right at the end
it was like that that episode of seinfeld and i
was like just living on kenny rogers roasters
for like two weeks we were there and his last
48 hours went through like two buckets of chicken
it was brutal it was brutal it smelled in there
and then i had a day and a half and i remember
joe lando from dr quinn was co-starring in it
he was our bad guy and he was a dear friend
he still is and i remember going to my room
and collapsing and you know the sound of a
hotel phone ringing that loud chirp it woke
me up about 18 hours later and have you ever woken
up from asleep so deep do you feel like you know
you got punched by mike tyson and you just you're
incoherent i remember the phone ringing waking up
and literally i couldn't see my eyes were open
and i was i was like mike tyson on his hands and
knees when he got knocked out and he was reaching
remember when he was looking for his mouthpiece
that was me looking for the phone i answered
it i had the upside down parts of my ear
i was like hello and joe's like shane it's joe
it's like and and he to this day he still makes
fun of me because i know the story and he goes
dude are you okay okay oh yes and he goes i think
i caught you is sleeping or something i'm gonna
call you back and i remember it woke me up and i
remember i had to call him back and i couldn't
find him and i was worried something was wrong
but yeah that's that's what that was like we
started shooting i think the next morning at 5am
with the script that the three of you had had
written yeah and then the director decided at
5am he wanted to be in the movie and he wasn't
written in the movie and turned to me and said why
don't you direct the opening scene i'm going to be
in this so that was my first directing job really
without getting a job so i shot the opening scene
of no code yeah the director decided to be in it
has dealing with kovid been the most difficult
stretch for you in your entire film career
dealing with covet has not been an issue other
than things got shut down i had a film that was
ready to go that was green lit that we were going
to be shooting the june after the march start of
covid so that was disappointing i've never had a
green light on a film and watched it completely
go away that was kind of heartbreaking i felt bad
for the cast i felt bad for the crew um i am never
bored i always find something to do and we've been
very very productive during covid i think between
two writers and i we've created over 30 pride
three writers and i've created with 30 projects
six screenplays uh i got involved with a health
and wellness documentary i've been helping kind
of oversee for pure flix that's been fun um but
as i told you earlier i just got to the point
where i said it's time to go back to work and you
know people are working there's a way to do this
and i have a lot of friends who have gotten back
on set and they're working i've got partners up
in canada right now shooting a film for hallmark
got other friends that are here in town shooting
you know at siren they're doing the will ferrell
and julian moore film and they're back to work
so we're chomping at the bit so i'm just more
restless now ready to go what do you see as the
new normal post covid whether whether a vaccine
is found whether people want to take the vaccine
it's still around people are still being
cautious god if you're going to go two years
on this interview strand then you're going to
prove me wrong what do i think the new normal is
i think i think the independent filmmaker is
going to thrive i think those who wear many hats
and know how to make films on a dime are going to
thrive because i wouldn't feel comfortable taking
my normal investors investment now i i am
working with my investors at a fraction
at one-fifth of their normal investment
strictly because i don't want to be shut
down during another pandemic i don't want to risk
hurting a large crew getting people sick i mean
like everybody else we're talking about a care a
story with maybe two actors here and two here and
maybe their story lines will intersect maybe they
won't and knock this thing out in a short amount
of time with a crew of six or eight i think
we'll generally get back i think we'll get
i think we'll get to a point where
people are going to get very complacent
um i i compared to you know we did a film in
the everglades years ago with emmett and ferla
and the everglades and there's alligators
all around and your first day on set you're
paranoid to move you're looking and there's eight
to twelve foot alligators everywhere you look and
then about by day three you stop being paranoid
and you get a little more comfortable and then by
day four or five you're throwing a football
with somebody and then the guy's like dude
you need to step forward about three feet you
got an eight-foot alligator like literally
right behind you and i think that's how
this is going to become i think eventually
i i don't see a vaccine coming anytime
soon it's just not the way it works
and if they shipped it from overseas i wouldn't
take it so i think i don't stand alone in that
stance i think we're happy to wear masks and ppe
and let's get the story told um safety first but
it's that way anyway you know you're not going to
put people in dangerous situations so you figure
out a way to stay socially distant responsible
i think if a crew can quarantine together then
they can work together it's working and you know
it worked with football until they all went home
it's worked with basketball i think there's no
reason we can't do that with making our films
i think the new normal post covid while
we have it is going to be smaller crews
shorter dates of shooting uh and just you
know figuring it out you know figuring it out
shane what protocols are you going to take for
your upcoming film in this covid reopening well i
mean you first and foremost you have to quarantine
everybody out 14 days which is important i think
everybody needs to know that they're clean going
in you have to test three times a week anybody
who's acting and anybody who's in zone a zone
a is considered the director of the dp hair and
makeup department anybody who's coming in regular
contact with the actors and then anybody in zone
b would be tested once a week but when you have
a smaller crew they assume everybody's in zone
a so everybody gets tested three times a week
so we'll test three times a week i am going to
take temperatures at least twice a day i'd like
taking temperatures every morning and then every
day after lunch unless we had something
spicy for lunch we'll do it before lunch
and we're just going to kind of stay tight and be
a traveling circus and just keep it intimate and
tight not let any outsiders and not let anybody
from the inside go out it's like hey if you're
committing and you're in you're in if you're not
that's cool we can't we can't do this obviously
everybody's going to have to wear ppe masks are
going to be mandatory actors will have to wear
masks until we say let's roll action um actors are
going to have to be comfortable doing their own
hair and makeup even though we'll have somebody
that handles props hair and makeup and wardrobe
i can't have them hovering so i want actors to
come camera ready and they can be touched up or
not doing a project that's elaborate we're not
doing mulan rouge um wardrobe is going to be
owned by the cast we're going to use our own
wardrobe we're going to keep it minimal changes
we're going to use locations that we control we're
not interested in using these locations that are
used by the general public or rented or chartered
for the day they're going to be okay we're going
to his house we're shooting at his house today
he's been quarantining there for two weeks
we're going outside to this ranch we're
going outside to this wash we're we're gonna
do stuff outside we have very minimal inside
actually the only interior scenes that we have
is an office that has been closed for months
that a friend of mine owns that he's given us and
a cabin out in the mountains that has been
vacated now for going on a year so um we
know it's clean and that's it as everything
else is exterior or in a car and when you say
no one's going out so how do you how do you
ensure that the cast and crew i mean i realize
they're going to have very little down time
but somebody could sneak down too hey you know
what it's on it's on them if if they want to if
they want to jeopardize it i can't i'm you know
i i work with people i've known a long time and i
trust we're going to have a crew of six to eight
we're gonna travel we're going to we're going
to be a traveling circus so if somebody wants to
sneak out of the motorhome i'm going to probably
know they're sneaking out of the motorhome i mean
you know we got two motorhomes they each sleep
they'll age sleep 10 but we're gonna have a
crew of six and four actors so you know we'll
know that's the only way i do it is you gotta
you gotta keep some form of control you know
that's what's happened is football why is football
getting the covid problem right now because
everything was controlled when these guys were
at training camp because they were they were kept
in a bubble just like basketball successfully did
and then as we all said let's take an office
pool you want to go four weeks or five before
the nfl starts shutting down games well people
go home then they start traveling and then they
come back from a game then they go out with their
friends and then they go to a strip club or they
go wherever and then they go play a game and then
these two teams play and these guys mingle and
then they take it all with them and that's what's
happening that's why you're seeing games getting
canceled and teams getting shut down we you
know it's happening now we're only in week three
and we're not even in the cold season and isn't
that when covert is that's what i think is going
to be the worst so yeah i mean we're going to
we're going to take all the precautions necessary
um we're just yeah that's how we're that's
the only way we can do it it's the only way
we can do it do you see yourself
flying anytime soon i love flying
but i mean it depends we
have a plane in the movie too
and somebody will be flying we got a little
piper cub but i mean in terms of commercials
taking a commercial flight yes with recycled i i
would not right now want to go on a plane i would
knowing knowing whether or not i've been exposed
to covet is the big mystery in the house but let's
say i have i wouldn't want to get on a plane now
because i think for the first time in our lifetime
we're thinking about the air we breathe and the
close contact we make with people we don't know
and i because the way we've all had to rethink and
relook at tight spaces oh the thought of being on
a plane with people right now or ever i don't
want to do it how does a director build strong
relationships with her actors director builds
strong relationships with actors you know it's
all about trust it's an actor's gonna decide in
the first 30 seconds of meeting a director if this
is somebody they can work with they've they've
sized you up it's almost like having a blind date
they size you up when you walk through the door
what can i get away with what are they going to
command for me are they going to stretch me and
make me into something better or can i put this in
cruise control and just kind of ride it out and
what i found is i i like to listen to an actor
um i like to let an actor know that i i run a set
that's very relaxed i i'm not a yeller i i trust
i said if you're here it's because i trust you now
we just got to get to the point where you trust me
so i let actors know that you know what's
important to me is i get the movie that we
need to make give me what i need and i'll give you
what you want every time if you show up prepared
and you're able to give me and the time allotted
to do the scene what i need i will give you what
you want and i know nine times out of ten what
you want is going to be better than what i need
and i find when i tell and that's true that's
not lip service i don't say that to every actor
but you know when i'm dealing with my leads
and people that i trust that have earned that
i find that barrier comes down and they start to
get excited and realize that this is a safe place
you know i i learned something very interesting
from martin sheen when we were doing a film
together 100 years ago he was telling the story
when he had a heart attack on apocalypse now
and he was being wheeled into surgery and his
dear wife jan looked over him and said it's
only an f in movie martin and he told that
story but apocalypse now is one of the most
known films in our history it's huge and i
never forgot that story and i never forgot that
it's only a movie you know relationships are
forever there's 33 000 movies a year that
are probably made through sag why is this one
going to be any more special than the next or
less important than the next it's only a movie
we're not curing cancer we're not curing kovid
what's most important is people feel better after
the experience than they did coming into it for me
and i want my actors to feel respected i want them
to feel like they can grow i want them to feel
like they can challenge me because i hope i become
a better filmmaker because of our experience you
know and i think if you go in allowing an actor
to stretch their legs keep them reined in when
you have to but trust when you make a decision on
an actor that is who you have entrusted that role
and that story to be told by through their eyes
and their vision i think it's important to let
an actor feel like they they can have the freedom
to play and to explore and experiment and then as
a as a director and an actor i think you can find
that middle ground where you're getting the story
and the performance that you need as a filmmaker
but as an actor and an artist they're being able
to to fly in a way that they don't feel stifled or
congested or condemned and i think if you can find
that balance when you look at some of the great
relationships that some directors and actors have
i mean you can look at spielberg and tom hanks or
zemeckis and tom hanks when they work together on
castaway and some of the other films and um you
you try to get one 100th of that greatness or that
relationship and and i find that i i've never
walked away working from it never walked away
working with an actor regretting the experience
didn't matter who it was or what the project was
i've never walked away from an actor regretting it
and i hope they feel the same for me do you think
um most sets are as stressful as apocalypse
now was or or what percentage i should say
i think i ever reached that point i think a lot of
sets are unnecessarily stressful it's something i
talk about in my book i think especially young
filmmakers put so much stress and pressure
they are making a movie because goddammit it's
getting in the sundance are our bust and that is
like the least thing you should be worried about
make a good movie learn and enjoy this experience
you may never do it again it's like it's like they
tell you and rudy you know you may be putting on
the football uniform for the last time enjoy it
live in the moment and i tell filmmakers that
this could be your one and only chance to tell
a story as a director before it fails and you
have to go sell stocks or become an insurance
salesman or whatever it is that you could do
nothing wrong with that but being a filmmaker is
a dream okay there's very few people who can make
a living at it so i always tell people look this
is this could be the only time you're ever going
to do it you might as well enjoy it and i think
if you enjoy it and the people around you feel
that you're enjoying it it's going to be a much
more pleasurable experience when people are happy
they deliver better things i find that people
put unnecessary stress on themselves because
they they just don't see it with the end in mind
they're so worried about what they're getting
and i think that's the importance of being
knowledgeable in editorial every filmmaker
before they want to you know before they become
a director before they become a writer i think
they need to spend three to five years in
the edit bay fixing other people's mistakes
because one reason i'm able to maintain a good
demeanor i know when i make a film it's because
i know when i nail something how i'm going to use
it i know exactly how many frames of it i'm going
to use i know exactly where in the story i'm going
to use it and it just it's not arrogance it's just
confidence it's knowing the craft of telling
a story doesn't mean my movies are great but
i look at something and i don't overshoot
i don't get a lot of takes i don't need it
i trust my cameraman i trust my actors and i trust
myself to tell the story and i think if people
can just kind of and it goes back to hiring the
right people people can just kind of take a breath
and enjoy the moment and just realize that
we are so blessed to be able to do this
i think they'd be pretty surprised with the
the outcome that they get when they look at the
dailies i think they'd be pleasantly surprised
and with apocalypse now weren't there things just
completely out of copela's control that i mean
what they were going on with the government at the
time you know with with the different locations
there is things happen there is always problems
on a film and as i as i try to stress and we've
talked about earlier i over pre-produce a film so
that way when something when a little bit you know
wheel comes off the wagon or a lug nut gets loose
it's not a catastrophe i'll give you an example we
were doing our last film i wrote a part or you
know cj wrote a part with with my request for a
specific actor i was a big fan of i fell in love
with an actor on a show i knew i could get to them
and i wrote a part for them and we made a deal
and this actor was going to be part of the film
and long story short the day we showed up to shoot
i got a call from her agent she said her father
just died she's got to jump on a plane and go to
detroit we're so sorry just reschedule it she'll
she'll be back in five six days rescheduled i
said i wish i could it's the only time i'm here
we work at a very quick pace we got
to figure this out i said i'm going
to go to you first you have another actor you
want to give me that you feel can do the role
and he was funny he was like i can't believe
you're not freaking out i said no i'm concerned
about the actor and her well-being for her dad
i will reach out to her but i said i want you
to think about somebody you have on your roster
you've got you've got 20 minutes before i start
making calls to other agents and he called me he
said i've got somebody and i don't want to name
names but it ended up being a pretty damn good cat
and it's it's about not losing it it's about just
taking a breath and realizing it's only a movie
it'll all figure itself out that's what we have
to do you know um the only way to make it work you
know our biggest day of shooting on break even i
had nine cameras i had an entire cast and half my
crew get food poisoning at the hotel from bad ice
where our call time that day was 8 a.m we're
supposed to start rolling cameras at 10.
i think people started showing up around 12 30
or 1 the ones that did show up and didn't go
to the hospital and i didn't start shooting my
biggest day of the film until 1 30 2 o'clock and
i i had a choice i could yell and scream i could
throw a fit i could kick a seagull was it the
ocean and i realized getting upset wasn't going to
make my casting group better it was only going to
let my existing cast and crew realize i was
out of control and i decided to just deal
with what we got let's make it work and you
know it worked of course when i watched the
scene back i wish i would have had more time
of course when i watched a scene back i wish i
would have gotten more angles but i'm pleased
with what we got and because of my knowledge
in post i knew exactly how we had to do this now
with a fraction of the time and it just comes from
confidence in telling a story being understanding
the editorial process so those are things that
are out of your control you know shot another
scene and there was a construction you know we
went and scouted it got a permit had a whole
scene and it turned out they started building
a house or demolishing a house right across
from it you know what do you do that's out
of your control and it's a very dialogue heavy
scene that you know you're not going to loot
so you you find the nicest person and the
most reasonable person on your crew to go
over and talk to the foreman and work out say hey
we're here for two hours can we do this can we
we go you go we go you go and they worked with
us you know it's what it's about what did gary
busey teach you about being a director gary busey
taught me so much about being a director the first
narrative i ever directed start gary busey
so talk about you know baptism under fire
um gary is unbelievably talented gary is he bro
you know he brought 40 years to the table i mean
there's a guy had done you know 75 movies when i
worked with him at this point here i was directing
my first i of course produced and written a lot of
stuff and never directed before so i learned how
to take a punch and i don't mean physically i mean
i learned how to take a punch and learn how to
to improvise i learned how to be strong because
when you're working with an actor like your
abuse you're the late dennis hopper those guys are
constantly testing you they they get more pleasure
out of trying to break you to find out how tough
you are and they're going to decide what they're
going to give you with your toughness and i found
you know when i produced a film with marlon brando
and i know his tricks and what he used to do to
directors and i'd watch him do it and he would
give two takes that were almost identical and see
which one the director liked better and if he knew
the director like the one he didn't really care
about then he he phoned it in he didn't care and
he he messed with directors and gary messes with
directors and dennis messed with directors and i i
encourage new filmmakers to go work with guys like
that because if you can cut your teeth on that
it's it's gonna you're gonna learn you're gonna
have seven years of film school in one day with a
guy like that and what was really cool about gary
is the way he helped me develop the character and
work through the character and what he demanded
and commanded of me as a filmmaker before we
started he was very involved in working this out
and making it happen and then when he showed up on
set it was so neat i remember we did take one and
i remember i said and cut and eternity goes notes
give me notes and i was like i got 25 people
looking at me waiting for me to go tell gary
busey academy award winner or academy award
nominee golden globe guy you know tell him and
i was scared to death and i walked up to him and i
realized what it was it was a show and i just went
up to i put my hands on his elbows to see gary
that was freaking brilliant i want to get it again
will that make you happy and you look at me and
goes dude come on they're all looking at us give
me a goddamn note alec i said a little bit more
pause when you go to sit down before you give
him that line that you know and he goes there we
go and that was the only noted game all day just
because he wanted a note and i was so out of my
league at the time and it's so out of out of the
you know knowing how to deal with the moment and
he covered me but he he he didn't need the note
he he showed up more prepared than anybody and
just knocked it out of the park and did exactly
what i had hoped he would and we had rehearsed
it but he tried to toughen me up and show me
that i need to be more vocal as a filmmaker in
front of people don't just say action cut that
was great let's get it again you know that was it
it's about interacting and i learned so much from
that experience and you know i've worked with some
great actors you know like jane seymour and you
know dennis hopper and you know good lord the list
goes on and on and um every one of those gives so
much to each project that we've done together
and i learn so much but gary yeah gary gary
was baptism by fire he kicked my ass right into
gear that was i knew once i once i rapped on busy
life got really easy it's amazing why would
an actor on that level of that caliber want
to test someone they it's about i think control
it's about how much i am willing to give and i'm
not it's like i look at it as a relationship if
you're in a relationship with somebody and you're
interested in taking that next level of intimacy
you're going to put some feelers out to see if
this is somebody that you can trust and go that
deep with emotionally and i think actors like
to try to break you down some of them are just
flat out [ __ ] and like to control a set and
those are who they are and gary was not that
way at all what he wanted to do is he wanted
to see he wanted to push my limits to see how
much he was willing to give back and the reason
he wanted to do the film it's a funny story i
sent the script to his son jake to play a part
gary intercepted it called me and said jake's
not available he's in miami doing a pilot for nbc
i read the script who's playing earl cooper and
i was like uh uh and there was an actor kind of
attached and he goes well i want to play it i've
done 75 films and i've never read a character
like this or been able to play this part and i'd
really like to play them i mean i i sorry to kind
of bogart the script but i i want to do it he
wasn't looking for a job he was busy and i wasn't
paying anything so it wasn't like he was getting
any money um so i went and met with him at his
house and we talked and just the first time i sat
with an actor of that caliber and listened to him
break down a script that i wrote and what he did
is he taught me the importance of what happens off
the page you know he said look you you know shane
you've given me you've given me page one to page
88. i'm more interested about what's before page
one and that's his story you know and gary went
into this guy's childhood and what made him who
he is today and it it really opened my mind as a
storyteller and as a writer and as a director
because now i understood how actors thought
so it was an amazing experience that i
would work with gary 100 times over and
you know twice on sunday it was a great experience
you